[Music]
well thank you all very much for coming
it's really shocking to me that you
don't have anything better to do one of
these days
no seriously though it is I mean you
know it's it's very strange in some
sense that there's so many of you here
to listen to a sequence of site of
lectures on the psychological
significance of the biblical stories it
isn't something I've wanted to do for a
long time but it still does surprise me
that there's a ready audience for it and
well alright so that's good so we'll see
how it goes
and I'll start with this because this is
the right question that the right
question is why bother doing this and I
don't mean why should I bother doing it
I have my own reasons for doing it but
you might think well why bother with
this strange old book at all and that's
a good question you know it's a
contradictory document that's being
cobbled together over thousands of years
it's outlasted kingdoms many many
kingdoms you know it's really
interesting that turns out that a book
is more durable than than a stone it's
more durable than a castle it's more
durable than an empire and that's really
interesting you know that it's something
in some sense so evanescent can be so
long living so there's that that's kind
of a mystery I'm I'm approaching this
whole scenario is the biblical stories
as if they're a mystery fundamentally
because they are there's a lot we don't
understand about them and we don't
understand how they came about we don't
really understand how they were put
together we don't understand why they
had such an unbelievable impact on
civilization we don't understand how
people could have believed them we don't
understand what it means that we don't
believe them now or or even what it
would mean if we didn't believe them
there
and then on top of all that there's the
additional problem which isn't specific
to me but it's certainly relevant to me
that no matter how educated you are
you're not educated enough to discuss
the psychological significance of the
biblical stories but I'm going to do my
best and partly because I want to learn
more about them and one of the things I
learned is that the best way to learn
about something is to talk about it and
when I'm lecturing I'm thinking you know
I'm not trying to tell you what I know
for sure to be the case because there's
lots of things I don't know for sure to
be the case I'm trying to make sense out
of this and I have been doing this for a
long time you know you know you may know
you may not that I'm an admirer of
Nietzsche Nietzsche was a devastating
critic of I would say dogmatic
Christianity Christianity as it was
instantiated in institutions I suppose
although he's a very paradoxical thinker
because for example one of the things
Nietzsche said was that he didn't
believe that the scientific revolution
would have ever got off the ground if it
hadn't been for Christianity and more
specifically for Catholicism because he
believed that over the course of really
a thousand years the European mind so to
speak had to train itself to interpret
everything that was known within a
single coherent framework coherent with
you except the initial axioms a single
coherent framework and so Nietzsche
believed that that Catholicism of the
phenomena of life and of history
produced the kind of mind that was then
capable of transcending that its
dogmatic foundations and then
concentrating on something else which in
this particular case happened to be the
natural world and so Nietzsche believed
that in some sense Christianity died at
its own hand it had spent a very long
period of time trying to attune people
to the necessity of the truth you know
absent the corruption and all about
that's always part of any human endeavor
and then the truth the spirit of the
truth that was developed by Christianity
turned on the roots of Christianity and
everyone woke up and said something like
or thought something like well how is it
that we came to believe any of this it's
like waking up one day and noting noting
that you really don't know why you put a
Christmas tree up but you've been doing
it for a long time and that's what
people do and you know there are reasons
that Christmas trees came about but the
what would you say the ritual lasts long
after the reasons have been forgotten
so now Nietzsche although he was a
critic of Christianity and also a
champion of its disciplinary capacity
because you see the other thing that
Nietzsche believed was that it was not
possible to be free in some sense unless
you go unless you had been a slave and
by that he meant that you don't go from
childhood to full-fledged adult
individuality you go from childhood to a
state of discipline which you might
think is akin to slavery to self-imposed
slavery that that would be the best
scenario where you have to discipline
yourself to become something specific
before you might be able to retain the
generality that you had as a child and
he believed that Christianity had played
that role for Western civilization but
in the late 1800s he announced that God
was dead and you often hear of that of
something triumphant but for Nietzsche
it wasn't because he was too nuanced to
think er to be that simple-minded see
Nietzsche understood that this is
something I'm going to try to make clear
is that we there's a very large amount
that we don't know about the structure
of experience that we don't know about
reality and we have our articulated
representations of the world and then
you could think of outside of that there
are things we know absolutely nothing
about and there's
offer between them and those are things
we sort of know something about and we
don't know them in an articulated way
here's an example you know sometimes
you're arguing with one of your someone
close to you and they're in a bad mood
you know and they're being touchy and
unreasonable and you keep the
conversation up and maybe all of a
sudden they you know they get angry
maybe they cry and then when they cry
they figure out what they're angry about
and it has nothing to do with you even
though you might have been what
precipitated the argument no one that's
an interesting phenomena as far as I'm
concerned because it means that people
can know things at one level without
being able to speak what they know at
another so in some sense the thoughts
rise up from the body and they do that
in moods and they do that in images and
they do that in actions and we have all
sorts of ways that we understand before
we understand in a fully articulated
manner and so we have this articulated
space that we can all discuss and then
outside of that we have something that's
more akin to a dream that were embedded
in and it's an emotional dream that were
embedded in and that's based at least in
part on our actions I'll describe that
later and then outside of that is what
we don't know anything about at all and
in that dream that's where the Mystics
live and that's where the artists live
and there are the mediators between the
absolute unknown and the things we know
for sure and you see what that means in
some sense is what we know is
established on a form of knowledge that
we don't really understand and that if
those two things are out of sync so you
might say if our articulated knowledge
is out of sync with our dream then we
become dissociated internally we think
things we don't act out and we act out
things we don't dream and that produces
a kind of sickness of the Spirit and and
that sickness of the Spirit it see its
cure is something like an integrated
system of belief and representation and
then people turn to things like
ideologies which I regard as parasites
on an underlying religious sub structure
to try to organize their thinking and
then that's a catastrophe and that's
what Nietzsche Nietzsche foresaw you see
he knew that when we knocked the slaps
out of the base of
civilization by destroying this
representation is this God ideal let's
say that we would destabilize and move
back and forth violently between
nihilism let's say and the extremes of
ideologies he was particularly concerned
about radical left ideology you know one
believed and predicted this in the late
1800s which is really an absolute
intellectual tour-de-force of staggering
magnitude predicted that in the 20th
century that hundreds of millions of
people would die because of the
replacement of these underlying
dreamlike structures with this rational
rational but deeply incorrect
representation of the world and you know
we've been oscillating back and forth
between left and right in some sense
ever since and you know with some good
sprinkling of nihilism in there and
despair some sense that's the situation
of the modern Western person and
increasingly of people in general you
know I think part of the reason that
Islam has its back up with regards to
the West to such a degree there's many
reasons and not all of them are valid
that's for sure but one of the reasons
is that you know they being still
grounded in a in a in a dream let's say
they can see that the rootless
questioning mind of the West poses a
tremendous danger to the integrity of
their culture now and it does I mean
Westerners us we undermine ourselves all
the time with our searching intellect
and I'm not complaining about passeth
you know I mean it
there isn't anything easy that can be
done about it but but it's still it's
still a sort of fruitful catastrophe and
you know it has real effects on people's
lives it's not some abstract thing you
know in me lots of times when I've been
treating people for depression for
example or anxiety they have existential
issues you know it's not just some
psychiatric condition it's it's not just
that they're tapped off of normal
because their brain chemistry is faulty
although you know sometimes that happens
to be the case it's that they are
overwhelmed by the suffering and
complexity of their life and they're not
sure why it's reasonable to continue
with it you know they can feel the
terrible negative meaning
of life but are skeptical beyond belief
about any of the positive meanings I had
one client was a very brilliant artist
and as long as he didn't think he was
fine you know because he don't create
and who is really good at being an
artist he just you know he had that
personality that was continually
creative and quite brilliant although he
was self denigrating and but as soon as
he started to think about what he was
doing then you know that the what was
it's like a like a drill or saw or
something like that he saw the branch
off that he was sitting on because he'd
start to criticize what he was doing
even the utility of it even though it
was sort of self evidently useful and
then he would be and it would be very
very hard for him to even motivate
himself to create and he always struck
me as a good example of of the
consequences of having your rational
intellect divorced in some way from your
being divorced enough so that it
actually questions the utility of your
being and it's not a good thing it's not
a good thing and it's really not a good
thing because it manifests itself not
only an individual psychopathology but
also in social psychopathology and
that's this proclivity of people to get
tangled up in ideologies which which I
really do think of as as they're like
they're like crippled religions that's
the right way to think about them
they're like religion that's missing an
arm and a leg but can still hobble along
and it it provides a certain amount of
security and group identity but it's
it's warped and twisted and demented and
Banten it's a parasite on something
underlying that's rich and true and
that's how it looks to me anyways and
and so so I think it's very important
that we sort out this problem I think
that I think that there isn't anything
more important that needs to be done
than that I've thought that for a long
long time probably since the early 80s
when I started looking at the psyche the
role that belief systems played in
regulating psychological and social
health because you can tell that they do
that because of how upset people get if
you challenge their beliefs
it's like why the hell do they care
exactly what difference does it make if
if all of your ideological axioms are a
hundred percent correct like people get
unbelievably upset when you when you
poke them in the axioms so to speak and
it isn't it is not by any stretch of the
imagination obvious why you know but
there's some it's like there's a
fundamental truth that they're standing
on it's it's like they're on the raft in
the middle of the ocean and you're
starting to pull out the logs you know
and they're afraid they're going to fall
in and drown
it's like drowning what and what are the
logs protecting themselves protecting
them from and why are they so afraid to
to move beyond the confines of the
ideological system and these are not
obvious things so I've been trying to
puzzle that out for a very long time and
I've done some lectures about data that
are on YouTube most of you know that and
some of what I'm going to talk about in
this series you'll have heard if you've
listened to the YouTube videos but you
know I'm trying to hit it from different
angles and so okay so Nietzsche's idea
was that human beings were going to have
to create their own values essentially
now he understood that we have bodies
and that we had motivations and emotions
like he was a romantic thinker in some
sense but way ahead of his time because
he knew that our capacity to think
wasn't some free-floating soul but was
embedded in our physiology constrained
by our emotion shaped by our motivation
shaped by our body he understood that
but he still believed that the only
possible way out of the problem would be
for human beings themselves to become
something akin to God and to create
their own values that was steps and he
thought that the person he talked about
the person who could create their own
values as the over man or the Superman
and that was one of the parts of
Nietzsche and philosophy that the Nazis
I would say took out of context used to
fuel their you know superior man
ideology so as we know what happened
with that that didn't seem to turn out
very well that's for sure and see I also
spent a lot of time reading Carl Jung it
was through Jung and also John Piaget
developmental psychologists that I
started to understand
and that our articulated systems of
thought are embedded in something like a
dream and that that dream is informed in
a complex way by the way we act so you
know me we act out things we don't
understand all the time and if that
wasn't the case then we wouldn't need a
psychology or a sociology or
anthropology or any of that because we
would be completely transparent to
ourselves and we're clearly not so we're
much more complicated than we understand
which means that the way that we behave
contains way more information than we
know and part of the dream that
surrounds our articulated knowledge has
been extracted as a consequence of us
watching each other behave and telling
stories about it for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years
extracting out patterns of behavior that
characterized humanity and trying to
represent them partly through limitation
but also through drama and mythology and
literature and arc and all of that to
represent what we're like so that we can
understand what we're like and that
process of understanding is what I see
unfolding at least in part in the
biblical stories and it's it's halting
and partial and awkward and
contradictory and and all of that which
is one of the things that makes the book
so complex but I see in it the struggle
of humanity to arise to rise above its
animal forebears say and to become
conscious of what it means to be human
and that's a very difficult thing
because we don't know who we are what we
are where we came from or any of those
things and you know the white life is an
unbroken chain going back three and a
half billion years it's an absolutely
unbelievable thing every single one of
your ancestors reproduced successfully
for three-and-a-half billion years it's
absolutely unbelievable we rose out of
the dirt in the muck and here we are
conscious but not knowing and we're
trying to figure out who we are and a
story that we've been telling her a set
of stories that we've been telling for
three thousand years seems to me to have
something to offer and so when when I
look at the stories in the Bible I do it
I would say in some sense with the
beginner's mind it's a mystery this book
how the hell it was made why it was made
why we preserved
how it happened to motivate an entire
culture for 2,000 years and to transform
the world like what's going on how did
that happen it's by no means obvious and
one of the things that bothers me about
casual critics of religion is that they
don't take the phenomena seriously and
it's a serious phenomenon I mean not
least because people have the capacity
for religious experience and no one
knows why that is and I mean you can
induce it reliably in all sorts of
different ways you could do it with
brain stimulation you could certainly do
it with drugs
there's especially the psychedelic
variety they produce intimations of the
divine extraordinarily regularly people
have been using drugs like that for god
only knows how long 50,000 years maybe
more than that to produce some sort of
intimate union with the divine it's like
we don't understand any of that when we
discovered the psychedelics in the late
60s it shocked everybody so badly that
they're instantly made illegal and
abandoned in terms of research for like
50 years and it's no wonder because who
the hell expected that nobody now now
Young was the student of Nietzsche's you
see him he was also I would say at the
very critic of Nietzsche he was educated
by Freud and Freud Freud I suppose in
some sense started to callate collate
the information that we had pertaining
to the notion that people lived inside a
dream you know it was Freud who really
popularized the idea of the unconscious
mind and we take this for granted to
such a degree today that we don't
understand how revolutionary the idea
was like with what's happened with Freud
is that we've taken all the marrow out
of his bones so to speak unless the husk
behind and you know now when we think
about Freud we just think about the husk
because that's everything that's being
discarded but so much of what he
discovered is part of our popular
conception now including the idea that
your perceptions and your actions and
your thoughts are all what would you say
informed and and shaped by unconscious
motivations that are not part of your
voluntary control and that's a very very
strange thing it's one of the most
unsettling things about the
psychoanalytic theories
so analytic theories are something like
your a loose collection of living
subpersonalities each with its own set
of motivations and perceptions and
emotions and rationales all of that and
you have limited control over that so
you're like a plurality of of internal
personalities that's loosely linked into
a unity you know that because you can't
control yourself very well which is one
of unions objections to needs his idea
that we could create our own values so
you didn't believe that especially not
after interacting with Freud because he
saw that human beings were affected by
things that were deeply deeply affected
by things that were beyond their
conscious control and no one really
knows how to conceptualize those things
you know the cognitive psychologists
think about them in some sense as
computational machines and the ancient
people I think thought of them as gods
although it's more complex than that
like rage would be of God Mars the
regard of rage that's the thing that
possesses you when you're angry you know
it has a viewpoint in it it says what it
wants to say and that might have very
little to do with what you want to say
when you're being sensible and it
doesn't just inhabit you it didn't
habits everyone and it lives forever and
it even inhabits animals and so it's
this transcendent psychological entity
that inhabits the body politic like like
the thought inhabits the brain that's
one way of thinking about it it's a very
strange way of thinking but it certainly
it certainly has its merit and so and
those things well in some sense those
are deities although it's not that
simple and so you feel was what got very
interested in dreams that started to
understand the relationship between
dreams and myths because he would see in
his clients dreams echoes of stories
that he knew because it was deeply read
in mythology and then he started to
believe that the dream was the
birthplace of the myth and that there
was a continual interaction between the
two processes the dream and the story
and storytelling and well you know you
tend to tell your dreams as stories when
you remember them and some people
remember dreams all the time like two or
three at night I've had clients like
that and they often have archetypal
dreams that have very clear mythological
structures
I think that's more the case with people
who are creative by the way especially
if they're a bit unstable at the time
because the dream tends to occupy the
space of uncertainty and to concentrate
on fleshing out the unknown reality
before you get a real grip on it so it's
like the dream is the birthplace of
thinking that's a good way of thinking
about it and so because it's the
birthplace of thinking it's not that
clear it's doing its best to formulate
something that was Jung's notion as
opposed to Freud who believed that there
were sensors internal sensors that were
hiding the dreams true message that's
not what you believed he believed the
dream was doing its best to express a
reality that was still outside of fully
articulated conscious comprehension it
was as you think look a thought appears
in your head right that's obvious spit
bang it's nothing you ever asked about
but what the hell does that mean a
thought appears in your head what kind
of ridiculous explanation is that you
know it just doesn't help with anything
where does it come from
well nowhere it just appears in my head
okay well that's not a very
sophisticated explanation as it turns
out you know and so you might think that
those thoughts thoughts that you think
well where do they come from well
they're often someone else's thoughts
right someone long-dead that might be
part of it just like the words you use
to think our utterances of people who be
long dead and so you're informed by the
spirit of your ancestors that's one way
of looking at it and your motivation
speak to your emotions speak to and your
body speaks to you and it all does all
that at least in part through the dream
and the dream is the birthplace of the
fully articulated idea it'll just come
from nowhere fully fledged right they
have a development large and god only
knows how how how lengthy that origin is
even to say something like I am
conscious you know that's taken
chimpanzees don't say that you know it's
been seven million years since we broke
from chimpanzees something like that
from the common ancestor you know they
have no articulated knowledge at all
they're very little self representation
in some sense
very little self-consciousness and
that's not the case with us at all and
we had to painstakingly figure all of
this out during that you know seven
million year voyage and I think some of
that's represented in and and and
captured in some sense in these ancient
stories which I believe were part of
especially the oldest stories in Genesis
which is the stories were going to start
with it that they were that that some of
the archaic nature of the human being is
encapsulated in those stories and it's
very very instructive as far as I can
tell and give you just a quick example
you know there's an idea of sacrifice in
in in the Old Testament and it's pretty
barbaric you know I mean the story of
Abraham and Isaac there's a good example
about because Abraham was called on to
actually sacrifice his own son which
doesn't really seem like something that
a reasonable God would ask you to do
right and the God in the Old Testament
it's frequently cruel and arbitrary and
demanding and paradoxical which which is
one of the things that really gives the
book life because it wasn't edited by a
committee you know a committee that was
concerned with with not offending anyone
that's for sure so
[Applause]
so Jung believed that the dream was the
birthplace of thought and I've been
extending that idea because one of the
things I wondered about deeply was you
know you have a dream and then someone
interprets it you can argue about
whether or not an interpretation is
valid just like you can argue about
whether your interpretation of a novel
or movie is valid right it's a very
difficult thing to determine with any
degree of accuracy counts in part for
the postmodern critique but my
observation has been that people will
present a dream and sometimes we can
extract out real useful information from
it that the person didn't appear to know
you know and they get a flash of insight
and to me that's a marker that we
stumbled on something that you nice part
of that person that wasn't United before
it pulls things together which is often
what a good story will do or sometimes a
good theory you know things snap
together for you there's a little light
goes on and that's one of the markers
that I've used for accuracy and dreams
and I know in my own family when I was
first married you know I'd have fights
with my wife arguments about this and
that and I'm fairly hot-headed and so I
get all puffed up and you know agitated
about about whatever we were arguing
about and she'd go to sleep which was
really annoying and it's so annoying
because I couldn't sleep right I like
chewing off my fingernails and she'd be
like sleeping peacefully beside me is
like maddening so but often she'd have a
dream you know and then the next morning
she discuss it with me and then we could
unravel what was at the bottom of our
argument and that was unbelievably
useful even though it was
extraordinarily aggravating so so you
know I was convinced by Jung it looked
to me like his ideas about the
relationship between dreams and
mythology and drama and literature made
sense to me in the and the and the
relationship between that and art I know
this native Carver he's a Wacka Wacka
he's carved a bunch of wooden sculptures
totem poles and masks that
have in my house and he's a very
interesting person not literate not
particularly literate and really still
steeped in this ancient 13,000 year old
tradition he's an original language
speaker and the fact that he hasn't
literate has sort of left him with the
mind of someone who's preliterate and
pre literate people aren't stupid
they're just not literate so their
brains are organized differently in many
ways and I've asked him about his his
intuition for his carvings and he's told
me that he dreams like you've seen the
Haida masks you know what they look like
his people are closely related to the
Haida so it's the same kind of style
he said he dreams in those animals and
and can remember his dreams and he also
talks to his grandparents who taught him
how to carve in his dreams quite often
if he runs into a problem with carving
his grandparents will come and he'll
talk to them but he sees that the
creatures that he's going to carve
living in an animated sense in his in
his imagination and I mean it's not that
difficult first of all I have no reason
to disbelieve him he's a very very
straightforward person and he doesn't
have the motivation or the guile I would
say in some sense to invent a story like
that there's just no reason he would
possibly do it I don't think he's told
that many people about it he thinks it's
kind of crazy you know said when he was
a kid he thought he was insane because
he'd had those dreams all the time about
these creatures and so forth and so it
wasn't something he was trumpeting but I
found it fascinating because I can see
in him part of the manifestation of this
unbroken tradition we have no idea how
traditions like that are really passed
along for thousands and thousands of
years right part of its oral and memory
part of its acted out and dramatized and
then part of its going to be imaginative
and people who aren't literate they
store information quite differently than
we do we don't remember anything it's
all written down in books right but if
you're from an oral culture especially
if you're trained in that way you have
all of that information at hand both so
you can speak it you can tell the
stories and you really know them and you
know modern people don't really know
what that's like any more doubt if
there's more than maybe two of you in
the audience that could spout from
memory like a 30 line poem you know when
poetry was written so
people could do that that that's why we
have that format so that people could
remember it and have it with them we
don't do any of that anymore
anyways back to you Ewan was a great
believer in the dream and I noted that
dreams will tell you things that you
don't know and then I thought well how
the hell can that be how that in the
world can something you think up tell
you something you don't know how does
that make any sense
first of all why don't you understand it
why does it have to come forth in the
form of the dream it's like you're not
there's something going on inside you
that you don't control right the dream
happens to you just like life happens to
you I mean there is the odd lucid
dreamer who can you know apply a certain
amount of conscious control but most of
the time it's you're laying there asleep
and this crazy complicated world
manifests itself inside you and you
don't know how you could you can't do it
when you're awake and you don't know
what it means it's like what the hell is
going on and that's one of the things so
damn frightening about the psychoanalyst
because you get this both from Freud and
Jung you really start to understand that
there are things inside you that are
happening that control you instead of
the other way around you know it is a
bit of reciprocal control but there's
manifestations of spirits so to speak
inside you that determine the manner in
which you walk through life and you
don't control it and what does is it
random you know there are people who
have claimed that dreams are mirror
merely the consequence of random
neuronal firing which is a theory I
think it's absolutely absurd because
there's nothing random about dreams you
know they're very very structured and
very very complex and they're not like
snow on a television screen or static on
a radio like those things are
complicated and and then also I've seen
so often that people have very coherent
dreams that have a perfect narrative
structure now they're fully developed in
some sense and so I just denied that
theory just doesn't go anywhere with me
I just can't see that as useful at all
and so so I'm more likely to take the
phenomena seriously say well there's
something to dreams while you dream of
the future
and then you try to make it into a
reality that seems to be an important
thing
or maybe you dream up a nightmare and
try to make that into a reality because
people do that too if they're hell-bent
on revenge for example and full of
hatred and resentment that manifests
itself in terrible fantasies you know
those are dreams then people go act them
out these things are powerful you know
when whole nations can get caught up in
collective dreams that's what happened
to the Nazis that's what happened to
Nazi Germany in the 1930s it was
absolutely remarkable amazing horrific
destructive spectacle and the same thing
happened in the Soviet Union the same
thing happened in China like we have
take these things seriously you know and
try to understand what's going on so you
believe that the dream could contain
more information than was yet
articulated you think artists do the
same thing you know like people go to
museums and they look at paintings
Renaissance paintings or modern
paintings and they don't exactly know
why they're there you know I was in this
room in in New York I don't remember
which museum but it was a room full of
Renaissance art you know great painters
the greatest painters and thought maybe
that room was worth a billion dollars or
something outrageous because there was
like 20 paintings in there you know so
priceless and the first thing is well
why are those paintings worth so much
and why is there a museum in the biggest
city in the world devoted to them and
why do people from all over the world
come and look at them what the hell are
those people doing one of them was of
the Assumption of Mary you know
beautifully painted absolutely glowing
work of art and like 20 people standing
in front of it looking at it and think
what are those people up to you know
they don't know why did they make a
pilgrimage to New York to come and look
at that painting it's not like they know
why is it worth so much I mean I know
there's a status element to it too but
that begs the question why do those
items become such high status items what
is it about them that's so absolutely
remarkable
well we're strange creatures so I was
trying to figure out in part well where
did the information that's in the dream
come from it has to come from somewhere
and you could think about it as a
revelation you know because it's like it
Springs out of the void it's new
knowledge and it's a revelation you
produce if it just it just appears but
that's seeing one of the things I want
to do with this series it's like I am
scientifically minded and I'm quite a
rational person and I like to have an
explanation for things that's rational
and empirical before I look for any
other kind of explanation and I don't
want to say that everything that's
associated with divinity can be reduced
in some manner to biology or to an
evolutionary history or anything like
that but insofar as it's possible to do
that reduction I'm going to do that and
I'm going to leave the other phenomena
floating in the air because they can't
be pinned down and in that category I
would put the category of mystical or
religious experience which we don't
understand at all so artists observe one
another they observe people and they
represent what they see and they
transmit the message of what they see to
us and they teach us to see and we don't
necessarily know what it is that we're
learning from them but we're learning
something or at least we're acting like
we're learning something we go to movies
we watch stories we we immerse ourselves
in fiction constantly that's an artistic
production and for many people the world
of the arts is a living world and that's
particularly true if you're a creative
person it's the creative artistic people
that do move the knowledge of humanity
forward and they do that with their
artistic productions first they're on
the edge and the dancers do that and the
poets do that and the visual artists do
that of the musicians do that and we're
not sure what they're doing we're not
sure what musicians are doing what the
hell are they doing why do you like
music you know gives you with deep
information of the significance of
things and then no one questions it you
go to a concert you're thrilled it's a
quasi-religious experience particularly
if the people really get themselves
together and get the crowd moving you
know there's something incredibly
intense about it but makes no sense
whatsoever it's not an easy thing to
understand music is deeply patterned and
patterned in layers and I think that has
something to do with it because reality
is patterned and deeply patterned in
layers and so I think music is
representing reality in some fundamental
way and that we get into this way of
that and sort of participate in being
and that's part
what makes it such an uplifting
experience but we don't really know
that's what we're doing we just go do it
and and and and it's nourishing for
people right I mean young people in
particular that lots of them live for
music it's where they derive all their
meaning their cultural identity you have
everything that's nourishing comes from
their affiliation with their music that
is part of their cultural identity so
that's an amazing thing the question
still remains where does the information
and dreams come from and I think what
where it comes from is that we watch the
patterns that everyone acts out we've
watched that forever and we've got two
representations of those patterns that's
part of our cultural history that's
what's embedded in stories in fictional
accounts of the story between good and
evil the bad guy and the good guy and
the romance you know these are these are
canonical patterns of being for people
and they deeply affect us because they
represent what it is that we will act
out in the world and then we flesh that
out with the individual information we
have about ourselves and other people
and so it's like there's a there's a
there's waves of behavioral patterns
that manifest themselves in the crowd
across time the great dramas are played
on the crowd across time and the artists
watch that and and they get intimations
of what that is and they write it down
and they tell us and then we're a little
clearer about what we're up to you know
like a great dramatist like Shakespeare
let's say is we know that what he wrote
is fiction and then we say well fiction
isn't true but then you think well mate
a minute maybe it's true like numbers
are true you know numbers are an
abstraction from the underlying reality
but no one in their right mind would
really think numbers aren't true you
could even make a case that the numbers
are more real than the things that they
represent right that the abstraction is
so insanely powerful
once you have mathematics you're just
deadly you can move the world with
mathematics so it's not obvious that the
abstraction is less real than than the
the more concrete reality and you take a
work of fiction like Hamlet you think
well is that it's not true because it's
fiction but
you think wait a minute what kind of
explanation is that maybe it's more true
than nonfiction because it takes what
the story that needs to be told about
you and the story that needs to be told
about you and you and you and you and
extracts that out says look here's
something that's a key part of the human
experience as such right so it's an
abstraction from this underlying noisy
substrate and people are affected by it
because they see that the thing that's
represented is part of the pattern of
their being that's the right way to
think about it and then with these old
stories these ancient stories it seems
to me like that process is being
occurring for thousands of years it's
like we watched ourselves and we
extracted out some stories we imitated
each other and we represented that drama
and then we distilled the drama and we
got a representation of the distillation
and then we did it again at the end of
that process that took god only knows
how long I think some of these stories
they've traced fairy tales back ten
thousand years some fairy tales in
relatively unchanged form and it
certainly seems to me that the
archaeological evidence for example
suggests that the really old stories
that the Bible begins with are at least
that old and likely embedded in a
prehistory that's far older than that
you might think well how can you be so
sure the answer to that in part is that
cultures that don't change like the
ancient cultures right they didn't
change as fast as they stay the same
that's the answer so they call they keep
their information moving generation to
generation that's how they stay the same
and so we know again in the
archaeological record there are records
of rituals that have remained relatively
unbroken for up to 20,000 years it was
discovered in caves in Japan that were
set up for a particular kind of bear
worship that was also characteristic of
Western Europe so these things can last
for very long periods of time we're
watching each other act in the world and
then the question is well how long have
we been watching each other and answer
that in some senses well as long as
there's being creatures with nervous
systems and that's a long time you know
that
some hundreds of millions of years
perhaps longer than that
we've been watching each other trying to
figure out what we're up to across that
entire span of time some of that
knowledge is built right into our bodies
which is why we can dance with each
other for example right because
understanding isn't just something that
you that you have as an abstraction it's
something that you act out you know
that's what children are doing when
they're learning to rough and tumble
plays they're learning to integrate
their body with the body of someone else
in a harmonious way learning to
cooperate and compete and that's all
instantiated right into their body it's
not abstract knowledge they don't know
that they're doing that they're just
doing it and so we can even use our body
as a representational platform so we've
been studying each other for a long time
abstracting out what is it that we're up
to and that's that that's what is it
we're up to what shouldn't we be up to
that's even a more fundamental question
if you're going to live in the world and
you're going to do it properly
what does properly mean and how is it
that you might go about that well it's
the right question right it's what
everyone wants to know how do you live
in the world not what is the world made
of it's not the same question how do you
live in the world it's the eternal
question of human beings and I guess
we're the only species that has ever
really asked that question because all
the other animals they just go and do
whatever they do not us it's a question
for us we've had to we have to become
aware of it we have to be able to speak
it god only knows why but that seems to
be the situation so we act that acting
is shaped by the world that acting is
shaped by society into something that we
don't understand but that we can model
that we can model we model it in our
stories we model it with our bodies and
that's where the dream gets its
information the dream is part of the
process that's watching everything and
then trying to formulate it and trying
to say well trying to get the signal out
from the noise and to portrayed in
dramatic form because it's dream is
little drama and then you get the chance
to talk about what that dream is and
then you have it you have something like
articulated knowledge at that point and
so the Bible I would say is is it's sort
of
it exists in that space that's half into
the dream and half into articulated
knowledge it's something like that and
going into it to find out what the
stories are about can what can what it
can aid our self understanding and then
the other issue is is that if nature was
correct and if Dostoyevsky or Jung was
correct in Dostoyevsky as well we
without the cornerstone that that
understanding provides were lost and
that's not good because then we're
susceptible to psychic pathology that's
psychological pathology there were
people who are adamant anti religious
thinkers seem to believe that if we
abandoned our immerse Minh tin the
underlying dream that we'd all instantly
become rationalists like Descartes or
bacon you know intelligent clear
thinking rational scientific people I
don't believe that for a moment because
I don't think there's any evidence for
it I think we would become so irrational
so rapidly that the weirdest mysteries
of Catholicism would seem positively
rational by contrast and I think that's
already happening so ok so this is the
idea essentially you know that you have
the unknown world
that's just what you don't know at all
that's that's outside that's the ocean
that surrounds the island that you
inhabit something like that it's chaos
itself and then you act in that world
and you act in ways you don't understand
there's more to your actions than you
can understand one of the things you
said I love this when I first understood
it he said everybody acts out a myth but
very few people know what their myth is
and you should know what your myth is
because it might be a tragedy and maybe
you don't want it to be and that's
really worth thinking because thinking
about because you're you have a pattern
of behavior that characterizes you you
know when god only knows where you got
it hardly it's biological partly it's
from your parents
it's your unconscious assumptions it's
the way the philosophy of your society
has shaped you and it's aimed
it's aiming you somewhere well is it
aiming you somewhere you want to go
that's a good question
that's part of self-realization you know
we know we don't understand our actions
that's almost every argument you have
with someone is about that it's like why
did you do that come up with some
half-baked reasons why you did it
you're flailing around in the darkness
you know you try to give an account for
yourself but you can only do it
partially it's very very difficult
because you're in your you're a
complicated animal with the beginnings
of an articulated mind something like
that and you're just way more than you
can handle and and all right so you act
things out right you act things out and
that's a kind of competence and then you
imagine what you act out and you imagine
what everyone else acts out and so
there's a tremendous amount of
information in your action and then that
information is translated up into the
dream and into art into mythology and
literature and there's a tremendous
amount of information in that and then
some of that is translated into
articulated thought and I'll give you a
quick example of something like that I
think this is partly what happens in
Exodus when Moses comes up with the law
you know he's wandering around with the
Israelites forever in the desert and
they're they're like going left and
going right worshipping idols and like
having a hell of a time and you know
getting rebellious and Moses goes up in
the mountain and he has this tremendous
revelation sort of in the sight of God
and illuminates him and he comes down
with the law you think well no Moses
acted as a judge I know this is a
mythological story Moses acted as a
judge in the desert he was continually
mediating between people who are having
problems constantly trying to keep peace
and so what are you doing when your turn
to keep peace is you're trying to
understand what peace is right you have
to apply the principles or what are the
principles well you don't know the
principles are whatever satisfies people
enough to make peace and maybe you do
that ten thousand times and then you get
some sense of oh here's the principles
that bring peace and then one day it
blasts into your consciousness like like
a revelation
here is the rules that we're already
acting out well that's the Ten
Commandments it's they're there to begin
with and Moses comes
and says look this is already basically
what we're doing but now it's codified
right and like that's all a historical
process that's condensed into a stay
single story but obviously that happened
because we have written law right and
that emerged in good legal systems that
emerges from the bottom up that's
English common law is exactly like that
right it's single decisions that are
predicated on principles that have been
then articulated and made into the body
of law the body of law is something you
act out that's why it's a body of law if
you're a good citizen you act out the
body of law and the body of law has
principles okay so the question is
there's principles that guide our
behavior what are those principles well
I think when you if you if you want the
initial answer of what the art archaic
Israelites meant by God that's something
like what they meant now it's not a good
enough explanation but look imagine that
you that you have a that you're a
chimpanzee you have a powerful dominant
figure at the pinnacle of your society
that represents power now more than that
because it's not sheer physical prowess
that keeps a chimp at the top of the
hierarchy it's much more complicated
than that but you could say well there's
there's a principle that the dominant
person manifests and then you might say
well that principle shines forth even
more brightly if you know ten people who
are dominant powerful then you can
extract out what dominance means from
that you can extract out what power
means from that and then you can divorce
the concept from the people and we had
to do that at some point because we can
say power in a human context and we can
imagine what that means but it's
divorced from any specific manifestation
of power well how the hell did we do
that like that's so complicated when we
if you're a chimp the power is in
another chimp it's not some damn
abstraction well so the so the question
is think think about it we're in these
hierarchies many of them across
centuries we're trying to figure out
what the guiding principle is we're
trying to extract out
core of the guiding principle and we
turn that into a representation of a
pattern of BA well it's something like
that that's God it's an abstracted ideal
and it's put in personified form it
manifests itself in personified form but
that's okay because what we're trying to
get at is the in some sense the essence
of what it means to be a properly
functioning and properly properly
functioning properly social and properly
competent individual we're trying to
figure out what that means you need a an
embodiment you need an ideal that's
abstracted that you could act out that
would enable you to understand what that
means and that's what we've been driving
at so that's the first hypothesis in
some sense I'm going to go over some of
the some of the attributes of this
abstracted ideal that we formalized as
God but that's the first sort of
hypothesis is that a philosophical or
moral ideal manifests itself first as a
concrete pattern of behavior that's
characteristic of a single individual
and then it's a set of individuals and
then it's an abstraction from that set
and then you have the abstraction it's
so important so here's a political
implication for example one of the
debates we might say between early
Christianity and the late Roman Empire
was whether or not an emperor could be
God literally right to be deified to put
in a to be good in the temple and you
can see why that might happen because
that's someone at the pinnacle of a very
steep hierarchy has a tremendous amount
of power and influence but the Christian
response to that was never confuse the
specific sovereign with the principle of
sovereignty itself
it's brilliant you see how difficult it
is to come up with an idea like that so
that even the person who has the power
is actually subordinate to something
else subordinate to let's call it a
divine principle for lack of a better
word so even the king himself is
subordinate to the
principle and we still believe that
because we believe that our president
our Prime Minister is subordinate to the
damn law whatever the body of law right
there's a principle inside that that
even the leader is subordinate to
without that you could argue you can't
even have a civilized society because
you're your leader immediately turns
into something that's transcendent and
all-powerful and I mean that's certainly
what happened in the Soviet Union and
what happened in Mao's China and what
happened in Nazi Germany because there
was nothing for the powerful to
subordinate themselves to you're
supposed to be subordinate to God so
what does that mean well we're going to
tear that idea apart but partly what it
means is that your subordinate even if
your sovereign to the principle of
sovereignty itself and then the question
is what the hell is the principle of
sovereignty and I could say we have been
working that out for a very long period
of time and so that's one of the things
that we'll talk about because the
ancient Mesopotamians and the ancient
Egyptians had some very interesting
dramatic ideas about that so it's for
example very briefly there was a deity
known as Marduk and mardik he was a
Mesopotamian dandy and imagine this is
sort of what happened is that as an
empire grew out of the post ice age age
say fifteen thousand years ago ten
thousand years ago all these tribes came
together and these tribes each had their
own daddy their own image of the ideal
but then they started to occupy the same
territory right and so then one tribe
had God a and one tribe had God B and
they one could wipe the other one out
and then it would just be God a who wins
but that's not so good because well
maybe you want to trade with those
people or maybe you don't want to lose
half your population in a war something
like that so then you have to have an
argument about who's God is going to
take priority which ideal is going to
take priority and what seems to happen
is that's represented in mythology as a
battle of the gods in sort of celestial
space but from a practical perspective
it's more like an ongoing dialogue you
believe this I believe this you believe
that I believe this how are you going to
meld that together so you take God a and
you take God being and maybe what you do
is extra
God see from them and you say well God
see now has the attributes of a and B
and then some other tribes come in and
then C takes them over too and so you
get like with Marduk for example he has
a multitude of names 50 different names
while those are names at least in part
of the subordinate gods that represented
the tribes that came together to make
the civilization that's part of the
process by which that abstracted ideal
is abstracted you think this is
important and it works because your
tribes alive and you think this is
tribe is alive and so we'll take the
best of both if we could manage it and
extract out something that's even more
abstract it covers both of us if we can
do it and one of the things that's
really interesting about Marduk I'll
just give you a couple of of his
features but he has eyes all the way
around his head he's elected by all the
other gods to be king God so that's the
first thing that's quite cool and they
elect him because they're they're facing
a terrible threat sort of like a flood
and a monster combined something like
that and Marduk basically says that if
they elect him top god then he'll go out
and stop the flood monster and and and
they will all get wiped out it's a
serious threat it's chaos itself making
its comeback and so all the gods agree
and Marduk is a new manifestation he's
got eyes all the way around his head and
he speaks magic words and then he also
goes out and when he fights he fights
this deity called taya math and we need
to know that because the word time at is
associated with the word teh home teh om
and tail MS the chaos that God makes
order out of at the beginning of time in
Genesis so it's linked very tightly to
the story and Marduk with his eyes and
his capacity to speak magic words goes
out to confront tire masses like a
watery sea dragon something like that
it's a classic it's a classic st. george
story quote and wreak havoc on the
dragon he cuts her into pieces and he
makes the world out of her pieces and
that's the world that human beings live
in and Mesopotamian Emperor acted out
Marduk he was allowed to be Emperor
insofar as he was a good Marduk so that
meant that he had eyes all the way
around his head and he could speak mad
you can speak properly and so that we're
starting to understand there at that
point the essence of leadership right
because what's leadership is the
capacity to see what the hell is in
front of your face and maybe in every
direction and then the capacity to use
your language properly in a
transformative manner and to transform
chaos into order and god only know how
those how long it took the Mesopotamians
to figure that out and the best they
could do is dramatize it but it's
staggeringly brilliant you know it's by
no means obvious and this chaos is chaos
is a very strange thing is this is the
chaos that God wrestled with at the
beginning of time chaos is what it's
half psychological and half real there's
no other way to really describe it the
chaos is what you encounter when you're
thrown into deep confusion right when
your world falls apart when when you
encounter something that blows you into
pieces when your dreams die when you're
betrayed
it's the chaos that emerges and the
chaos is everything at once and it's too
much for you and that's for sure and it
pulls you down into the underworld and
all that's where the Dragons are and all
you've got at that point is your
capacity to bloody well keep your eyes
open and to speak as carefully and
clearly as you can and maybe if you're
lucky you'll get through it that way and
come out the other side and it's taken
people a very long time to figure that
out and it looks to me like the idea is
erected on the platform of our ancient
ancestors maybe tens of millions of
years ago because we seem to represent
that which disturbs us deeply using the
same system that we use to represent
like serpent Isle serpent Isle or other
carnivorous predators and it you know
we're biological creatures right so when
we formulated our capacity to abstract
our strange capacity abstracted use
language we still have all those
underlying systems that were there when
we were only animals and we have to use
those systems they're they're part of
the emotional and motivational
architecture of our thinking and part of
the reason we can demonize our enemies
who upset our axioms is because we
perceive them as if they're carnivorous
predators we do it with the same system
and that's chaos itself the thing that
always threatened
us right the snakes that came to the
trees when we lived in them like 60
million years ago it's the same damn
systems so the mardik story is partly
the story of using attention and
language to confront those things that
most threatened us and some of those
things are real real world threats but
some of them are psychological threats
which are just as profound but far more
abstractly but we use the same systems
to represent them it's why you freeze if
you're frightened right you're a prey
animal you're like a rabbit you've seen
us you've seen something that's going to
eat you you free and that way your
paralyzed your turn to stone which is
what you do when you see a Medusa with a
head full of staying snakes right you
turn to stone you're paralyzed and the
reason you do that is because you're
using the predator detection system to
protect yourself your heart rate goes
way up and you get ready to move things
that upset us rely on that system and
then the story the mardik story for
example is the idea that if there are
things that upset you chaotic terrible
serpentine monstrous underworld things
that threaten you the best thing to do
is to open your eyes and get your speech
organized and go out and confront the
thing and make the world out of it and
it's it's staggering what I when I read
that story and started to understand it
just blew me away that it's such a
profound idea and we know it's true too
because we know in psychotherapy for
example that you're much better off to
confront your fears head-on then you are
to wait and let them find you and so
partly what you do if you're a
psychotherapist is you help people break
their fears into little pieces the
things that upset them and then to
encounter them one by one and master
them and so you're teaching this process
of eternal mastery over the strange and
chaotic world and that now all of that
makes up some of the backgrounds we
haven't even got to the first sentence
of the biblical stories yet
but all of that makes up the background
so you have to think that we've
extracted this story these are the
extrange collection of stories with all
its errors and its and its repetitions
and and its peculiarities out of the
entire like the entire history that
we've been able to collect ideas and
it's the best we've been able to do and
I know there are other religious
traditions not concerned about that at
the moment because we can use this as an
example but it's the best we've been
able to do and what I'm hoping is that
we can return to the stories in some
sense with an open mind and see if
there's something there that we actually
need and hope and I hope that that will
be the case and as I said I'll approach
it as rationally as I possibly can so
well this is the idea to begin with who
knows we have the unknown as such and
then we act in it like animals act they
act first they don't think they don't
imagine they act and that's that's where
we started we started by acting and then
we started to be able to represent how
we acted and then we started to talk
about how we represented how we acted
and that enabled us to tell stories
because that is what a story is it's to
tell about how you represent how you act
and so you know that because if you read
a book what happens you read the book
and images come to mind of the people in
the book behaving right it's one step
from acting and outfits
you don't act it out because you can
abstract you can represent action
without having to act it out
it's amazing thing and that's part of
the development of the prefrontal cortex
it's part of the capacity for human
abstract thought is you can hold
behavior the representation of the
behavior away from the behavior and
manipulate the representation before you
enacted it that's why you think it's so
that you can generate a pattern of
action and test it out in a fictional
world before you embody it and die
because you're foolish right you let the
representation die not you and that's
why you think and so that's partly what
we're trying to do with these stories
what do I hope to accomplish I hope to
end this 12 lecture series knowing more
than I did when I start
that's my goal because I said that you
know not telling you what I know I'm
trying to figure things out and and and
and this is part of the this is part of
the process by which I'm doing that and
so I'm doing my best to think on my feet
you know I'm going to come prepared but
I'm trying to stay on the edge of my
capacity to generate knowledge and to
make this continually clearer and to get
to the bottom of things and so I'm
hoping that that's what I'm that's what
I want to accomplish and it seems like
people are interested in that so then
we're going to try to accomplish that
together and so that's the that's the
plan and the idea is to see if there's
something at the bottom of this amazing
civilization that we've managed to
construct that I think is imperiled for
a variety of reasons and maybe if we
understand it a little bit little bit
better we won't be so prone just to
throw the damn thing away which i think
would be a big mistake and to throw it
away because of resentment and hatred
and bitterness and historical ignorance
and jealousy and and and the desire for
destruction and all of that it's like I
don't want to go there it's a bad idea
to go there and we need to be grounded
better and so hopefully well we'll see
how this works all right so how do I
approach this well first of all I think
in evolutionary terms you know as far as
I'm concerned the the cosmos is 15
billion years old and the world is
four-and-a-half billion years old and
there's been life for 3 and 1/2 billion
years and an older there were creatures
that had pretty developed nervous
systems 300 to 600 million years ago and
we were living in trees as small mammals
60 million years ago and we we were down
on the plains between 60 million and 7
million years ago and that's about when
we split from chimpanzees and modern
human beings seemed to emerge about 150
thousand years ago and civilization
pretty much after the last ice age
something after fifteen thousand years
ago not very long ago at all you know
and that's that that's the span across
which I want to understand that's the
span across which I want to understand I
want to understand why
our the way we are looking at life and
it's in its continual complexity right
from the beginning of life itself and
there's some real utility in that
because we share attributes with other
animals even Apple Apple animals as
simple as crustaceans for example have
nervous system properties that are very
much like ours and it's very much worth
worth knowing that so I think in an
evolutionary way I think it's a grand
and remarkable way to think because it
has this incredible time span right it's
just amazing I mean people at the end of
the 19th century middle of the 19th
century say thought the world really
thought the world was about 6,000 years
old I mean 15 billion years old that's a
lot more right it's a lot grander it's a
lot bigger but it's also a lot more
frightening and an alienating in some
sense because you know the cosmos has
become so vast it's either easy for
human beings to think of themselves as
trivial specks on a trivial speck some
misbegotten tell who'll end of the
galaxy among hundreds of millions of
galaxies right it's it's very easy to
see yourself as nothing in that span of
time that's a real challenge for people
and and I think it's a mistake to think
that way
because I think consciousness is far
more than we think it is but it's still
something we have to grapple with I'm a
psychoanalytic thinker and what that
means is that I believe that people are
collections of sub personalities and
that those sub personalities are alive
they're not machines they're there they
have their viewpoint they have their
wants they have their perceptions they
have their arguments they have their
emotions they're they're like low
resolution representations of you you
know when you get angry it's like it's a
very low resolution representation of
you it only wants rage or it only wants
something to eat or only once they only
wants water only wants sex it's it's you
but shrunk and focused in a specific
direction and and those all those
motivational systems are very very
ancient very archaic and very very
powerful and they play a determining
role in the manner in which we manifest
ourselves as Freud pointed out with the
in we have to figure out how to take all
those underlying animalistic motivations
and emotions and civilize them in some
way so that we can all live in the same
general territory without tearing each
other to shreds which is maybe the
default position of both chimpanzee and
humanity so so I take that seriously the
idea that we're a loose collection of
spirits and that not that you know it
says in the Old Testament somewhere that
the fear of God is the beginning of
wisdom and I think this is akin to that
if you know that you're not in control
of yourself thoroughly and that there
are other factors behind the scenes like
the Greek thought that human beings were
the playthings of the gods that's the
way they conceptualized the world they
sort of meant the same thing they meant
that there are these great forces that
would move us that we don't create it
were that were that we're subordinate to
in some sense not entirely but we could
be subordinate to them and they move our
destinies that was the Greek view and
there's something it teaches you
humility to understand that that that
there's a hell of a lot more going on
behind the scenes and you're you're the
driver of a very complex vehicle but you
don't understand the vehicle very well
and it's got its own motivations and
methods and sometimes you think it's
doing something and it's doing something
completely completely different you see
that in psychotherapy all the time
because you know you help someone unwind
the pattern of behavior that they've
manifested forever first of all they
describe it then they become aware of it
then maybe they start to see what the
cause is they have no idea why they were
acting like that you know they have to
have the memory that produced the
behavioral pattern to begin with it has
to be brought back to mind and then it
has to be analyzed and assessed and then
they have to think about a different way
of acting and it's extraordinarily
complex so psychoanalytic literary well
there's this new there's this postmodern
idea about literature and about the
world for that matter that if you take a
complex piece of literature like like a
Shakespeare play there's no end to the
number of interpretations that you can
make of it
you know you can eat turf at each words
you can interpret each phrase each
sentence each paragraph you could
interpret the entire play the way you
interpret it depends on how many other
books you've read
depends on your orientation in the world
it depends on a very very large number
of things how cultured you are or how
how much culture you lack all of those
things it opens up a huge a huge Vista
for potential interpretation and so the
postmodern sort of stubbed their toe on
that and thought well if there's this
vast number of interpretations of any
particular literary work how can you be
sure that any interpretation is more
valid than any other interpretation and
if you can't be sure then how do you
even know those are great works how you
know they can't maybe they're just works
that the people in power have used to
facilitate their continual accession of
power which is really a postmodern idea
very very cynical one but it has its
point but the thing is it's grounded in
something real right it's like yes you
can interpret things forever
I want to show you something here just
briefly we'll go back to it later look
at this this is the cool one of the
coolest things I've ever seen so at the
bottom here every single one of those
lines is a biblical verse okay
now the length of the line is
proportionate to how many times that
verse is referred to in some way by some
other verse so you say well this is the
first type or length book right I'm not
dead serious about that if you like that
you can't click and get the hyperlinks
obviously but it's a thoroughly
hyperlink book and it's because well the
people who worked on these stories that
are hypothetically at the end right
which is the end can't affect the
beginning that's that's the rule of time
right what happens now can't affect what
happened to you 10 years ago even though
it actually can but whatever
well you reinterpret things right and
then they're not the same but whatever
we won't get into that but technically
speaking the present cannot affect the
past but if you're looking at a piece of
literature that's not right because when
you write the end you know what it was
at the beginning and when you write the
beginning or edit it you know what's at
the end so you can weave the
whole thing together and there's 65,000
cross-references and that's what this
map shows and so that's a great visual
representation of the book and then you
can see well why is it deep why is the
book deep well just imagine how many
pathways you could take through that
right I mean you just journey through
you just journey through that forever
you'd never ever get to the end of it
there's permutations and combinations
and every phrase is dependent on every
other phrase in every verse is dependent
on every other not entirely but 65
thousands is not a bad start so okay
well so so that's another issue in some
sense that seems to make the post
modernist critique even more correct how
in the world you're going to extract out
a canonical interpretation of something
like that it's like it's not possible
but here's the issue as far as I can
tell the interpret so the post
modernists extended that critique to the
world they said look while a text is
complicated enough
you can't extract out a canonical
interpretation what about the world the
world is way more complicated than a
text and so there's an infinite number
of ways that you can look at the world
and so how do we know that any one way
is better than any other way that's a
good question
now the postmodern answer was we can't
and that's not a good answer because you
drown in chaos under those circumstances
right you can't make sense of anything
and that's not good because it's not
neutral to not make sense of things
it's very anxiety-provoking it's very
depressing because if things are so
chaotic that you can't get a handle on
them your body defaults into emergency
preparation mode and your heart rate
goes up at your immune system stops
working and like you burn yourself out
you AIDS rapidly because you're
surrounded by nothing you can control
burying that's an existential crisis
right it's anxiety provoking and
depressing very hard on people and even
more than that it turns out that the way
that we're constructed neuro
physiologically is that we don't
experience any positive emotion unless
we have a name and we can see ourselves
progressing towards that Abe it isn't
precisely attaining the aim that makes
us happy as you
all know if you've ever attained
anything because soon as you attain it
then the whole little game ends then you
have to come up with another game right
so it's it's is ah--this and now that's
ok but but it does show that the
attainment can't be the thing that
drives you because it collapses the game
that's what happens when you graduate
from university it's like you're king of
the mountain for one day and then you're
like surf fest yes at Starbucks for the
next 5 years and also yeah so what
happens is let that human beings are
weird creatures because we're much more
activated by having an aim and moving
towards it than we are by attainment and
what that means is you have to have an
aim and that means you have to have an
interpretation and it also means that
the nobler they aim that's one way of
thinking about it the better in your
life and that's a really interesting
thing to know because you know you've
heard ever since you were tiny that you
should act like a good person you
shouldn't live for example and you might
think well why the hell should I act
like a good person and why not lie and
even a three-year-old can ask that
question because smart smart kids learn
to lie earlier by the way and then they
think well why not
twist the fabric of reality so that it
serves your specific short-term needs I
mean that's a great question why not do
that why act morally if you can get away
with something and it brings you closer
to something you want oh why not do it
these are good questions it's not
self-evident well it seems to me tied in
with what I just mentioned it's like you
destabilize yourself and things become
chaotic that's not good and if you don't
have a noble aim then you have nothing
but but shallow trivial pleasures and
they don't sustain you and that's not
good because because life is so
difficult so much it's so much suffering
it's so complex it ends and everyone
dies and it's painful it's like without
a no blame how can you withstand any of
that you can't you become desperate and
once you become desperate things go
things go from bad to worse very rapidly
when you become desperate and so there's
the idea of the noble aim and it's not
something it's something that's
necessary it's the bread that people
cannot live without right that's not
physical bread it's the no blame and
what is that well it was encapsulated in
part of the story of Marduk that's
that's it's to pay attention it's to
speak properly it's to confront chaos
it's to make a better world it's
something like that and that's enough of
the noble aim so that you can stand up
without you know cringing at the very
thought of your own existence so that
you can do something that's worthwhile
to justify your wretched position on the
planet so now there's this the literary
issue is that so look you take a text
you can interpret in a variety of ways
but that's not right this is where the
postmodernist went wrong because what
you're looking for in a text and in the
world for that matter is is sufficient
order and direction so then we have to
think well what is sufficient order and
direction means well you don't want to
suffer so much that your life is
unbearable right now just seems
self-evident Payne argues for itself
I think of Payne as the fundamental
reality because no one disputes it right
I mean even if you say that you don't
believe in pain it doesn't help when
you're in pain you still believe in it
right it's you can't pry it up with
logic and rationality it just stands
forth as as what the fundamental
existence and that's actually quite
useful to know say well you don't want
any more of that than is absolutely
necessary and I think that's
self-evident and then you say wait a
minutes more complicated than that you
don't want any more of that that's
necessary today but also not tomorrow
and not next week and not next month and
not next year so however you act now
better not compromise how you're going
to be in a year because I'll just be
counterproductive that's part of the
problem with short-term pleasures right
it's like active haste repent at leisure
everyone knows exactly what that means
so you have to act in a way that works
now a.m. tomorrow and next week and next
month and so forth and so you have to
take your future self into account and
human beings can do that and taking your
future self into account isn't much
different than taking other people into
account right because I remember there's
this Simpson episode
and homer downs a quart of mayonnaise
and vodka he said someone Marge says you
know you shouldn't really do that and
Homer says that's a problem for future
Homer I said I'm sure glad I'm not that
guy
and so ridiculous to call me for you
know but but okay but you see we have to
grapple with that and so the you that's
out there in the future is sort of like
another person and so figuring out how
to conduct yourself properly in
relationship to your future self isn't
much different than figuring out how to
conduct yourself in relationship to
other people but then we can expand the
constraints not only does the
interpretation that you extract have to
protect you from suffering and give you
an aid but it has to do it in a way
that's iterable so it works across time
and then it has to work in the presence
of other people so that you can
cooperate with them and compete with
them in a way that doesn't make you
suffer more and people are there they're
not that tolerant you know I mean they
have choices they don't have to hang
around with you they can hang around
with any one of these other primates and
so if you don't act properly at least
within certain boundaries it's like
you're just cast aside and so people are
broadcasting information at you all the
time about how you need to interpret the
world so they can tolerate being around
you and you need that because socially
isolated you're insane and then you're
dead no one can tolerate being alone for
any length of time
we can't maintain our own sanity with a
continual feedback from other people
because it's too damn complicated so
you're constrained by your own existence
and then you're constrained by the
existence of other people and then
you're also constrained by the world no
if I read Hamlet and what I extract out
of that is the idea that I should jump
off a bridge it's like it's it puts my
interpretation to an end relatively it
doesn't seem to be optimally functional
let's say and so an interpretation has
is constrained by the reality of the
world it's constrained by the reality of
other people and it's constrained by
your reality across time there's only a
small number of interpretations
that are going to work in that tightly
defined space and so that's part of the
reason that the post modernists are
wrong it's also part of the reason by
the way that AI people who've been
trying to make intelligent machines have
had to put them in a body if it turns
out that you just can't make something
intelligent in some sense without it
being embodied and it's partly for the
reasons that I just described you need
constraints on the system before you
need constraints on the system so that
the system doesn't drown in an infinite
sea of interpretation it's something
like that so that's the literary end of
it moral well morality for me is about
action and then I'm an existentialist in
some sense what that means is that I
believe that what people believe to be
true is what they act I hope not what
they say and so there's lots of
definitions of truth in truth is a very
expansive word and you can think of
objective truth but behavioral truth
isn't the same as objective truth what
you should do isn't the same as what is
as far as I can tell people debate that
but I think the reasoning that that has
to be the case is because think about it
this way you're standing in front of a
field and you can see the field but the
field doesn't tell you how to walk
through it there's an infinite number of
ways you could walk through it and so
you can't extract out an inviolable
guide how you should act from the array
of facts that are in front of you
because there's just too many facts and
they don't have directionality and but
you you need to know you need to know
how not to suffer and you need to know
what your aim is and so you have to
overlay that objective reality with some
interpretive structure and its nature
that interpretive structure that we're
going to be aiming at hard giving you
some hints about it already we've
extracted it in part from observations
of our own behavior and other people's
behavior and we've extracted it in part
by the nature of our embodiment that's
been shaped over hundreds of millions of
years but we see the infinite plane of
facts and we impose a moral
interpretation on it and the moral
interpretation is what to do about what
is and that's associated both with
security because you just don't need to
complexity and also with aim and so
we're mobile creatures right we need to
know where we're going because all we're
ever concerned about roughly speaking is
where we're going that's what we need to
know where are we going what are we
doing and why and that's not the same
question as what is the world made of
objectively it's a different question
requires different answers and so that's
the domain of the moral as far as I'm
concerned which is what are you aiming
at what and that's the question of the
ultimate ideal in some sense even if you
have trivial little you know fragmentary
ideals this is something trying to
emerge out of that that's it's more
coherent and more integrated and more
applicable and more practical and that's
the other thing is that you know you
think about literature and you think
about arts and you think those aren't
very tightly tied to the earth they're
in period in Airy and spiritual and and
they don't seem practical but I'm a
practical person and part of the reason
that I want to assess these books from a
literary and aesthetic and evolutionary
perspective is to extract out something
of value something of real value that's
practical
you know something because one of the
rules that I have when I'm lecturing is
that I don't want to tell anybody
anything that they can't use because I
think of knowledge as a tool it's it's
something to implement in the world
where tool using creatures and our
knowledge is tools and we need tools to
work in the world we need tools to
regulate our emotions and to make things
better and to put an end to suffering to
the degree that we can and to live with
ourselves properly and to stand up
properly and you need the tools to do
that and so I don't want to do anything
in this lecture series that isn't
practical you know I would want you to
come away having things put together in
a way that you can immediately imply not
interested in abstraction for the sake
of abstraction rational well it's got to
make sense you know because the more
restrictions on your theory the better
and so I want it all laid out causally
so that a and
a full or B follows a and B precedes C
and in a way that's understandable and
doesn't require a leap any unnecessary
leap of faith you know because that's
another thing that I think interferes
with our relationship with a collection
of books like the Bible is that you're
called upon to believe things that no
one can believe and that's no good
because that's a form of lie as far as I
can tell and then well then you have to
scrap the whole thing because in
principle the whole thing is about truth
and if you have to start your pursuit of
truth by swallowing a bunch of lies then
how in the world are you going to get
anywhere with that and so I don't want
any uncertainty at the bottom of this or
I don't want any more than I can eat
them and I have to leave in it because I
can't get any farther than that and so
we it's going to make sense rationally I
want it I don't want it to be pushing up
against what we know to be
scientifically untrue even though
science is in flux and that's you know
somewhat of a dangerous parameter I
don't want if it isn't working with
evolutionary theory for example then I
think that it's not a good enough
solution so and then finally it's
phenomenological modern people you know
we think of the reality as objective and
that's very powerful but that isn't how
we experience reality we have our domain
of experience you know on and it's this
is a hard thing to get a grip on even
though it should be the most obvious
thing for the phenomenal just everything
that you experience is real and so
they're interested in the structure of
your subjective experience let me say
what you have subjective experience and
you have subjective experience so to you
and there's commonalities across all of
those like for example you're you're
likely to experience the same set of
emotions you know we've been able to
identify canonical emotions and
canonical motivations without that we
couldn't even communicate because you
wouldn't know what the other person was
like you'd have to explain infinitely
there's nothing you could take for
granted but you can you know when
phenomenology is the fact that in the
center of my vision my hands are very
clear and then out
periphery they get they disappear and
phenomenology is the way things smell
and the way things taste and the fact
that they matter and so you could say in
some sense that phenomenology is is the
study of what matters rather than matter
and it's a given from the
phenomenological perspective that things
have meaning that it is Andy you know
even if you're a rationalist say a cynic
and Annihilus can you say well nothing
has any meaning you still run into the
problem of pain because pain undercuts
your arguments and has a meaning so
there's no escaping from the meaning you
can pretty much demolish all the
positive parts of it but trying to think
your way out of the negative parts man
good luck with that because that just
doesn't work so phenomenology is and
there are the Bible stories and I think
this is true fiction in general is
phenomenological and it concentrates on
trying to elucidate the nature of human
experience and that is not the same as
the objective world but it's also a form
of truth because it is true that you
have a field of experience and that it
has qualities the question is what are
the qualities now ancient
representations of reality were sort of
a weird meld of observable phenomena
things that we would consider objective
facts and subjective truth the
projection of subjective truth and I'll
show you for example I'll show you how
they've Mesopotamians viewed the world
my data they had a model basically the
world was a disc you know if you go out
in the field at night what does the
world look like of the disc it's got a
dome on top of it
well that was basically the Mesopotamian
view of the world having that view of
the world that the people who wrote the
first stories in the Bible believe - and
on top of the dome there was water well
obviously it's like it rains right where
does the water come from
well there's water around the dome and
then there's land that's the disc and
then underneath that there's water how
do you know that well drill you'll hit
water what's under there it's obviously
because otherwise how would you hit the
water and then what's under that it's
fresh water and then what
that well you go to the edge of the disk
you hit the ocean it's salt water so
it's dome with water outside of it and
then it's a disc that the dome sits on
and then underneath that there's fresh
water and then underneath that there's
saltwater and that was roughly the
Mesopotamian world and you see you see
that's a mix of observation and
imagination right because that isn't the
world but it is the way the world
appears it's a perfectly believable
cosmology from and the Sun rises and the
Sun sunsets on that dome it's not like
the thing is bloody well spinning who
would ever think that up it's obviously
the Sun comes up it goes down and then
travels underneath the world it comes
back up again there's nothing more
self-evident than that well that's
that's that strange intermingling of
subjective fantasy let's say right at
the level of perception and actual
observable phenomena and a lot of the
cosmology that's associated with the
biblical stories is exactly like that
it's half psychology in half and half
and half reality although the
psychological is real as well so so
that's and then to know that the
biblical stories have a phenomenological
truth is really worth knowing because
you know the poor fundamentalists
they're trying to cling to their moral
structure and you know I understand why
because it does organize their societies
and it organizes their psyche so they've
got something to cling to but you know
they don't have a very sophisticated
idea of the complexity of what
constitutes truth and they try to
gerrymander the biblical stories into
the domain of scientific theory you know
procreative promoting creationism for
example as an alternative scientific
theory it's like this just that just
isn't going to go anywhere you know
because the people who wrote these
damned stories weren't scientists to
begin with there weren't any scientists
back then there's hardly any scientists
now you know it's really it's hard to
think scientifically man it's like it
takes a lot of training and even
scientists don't think scientifically
once you get them out of a lab and
hardly even when they're in the lab
we got to get peer-reviewed and
criticized and like it's hard to think
scientifically so and however the people
who wrote these stories thought was more
like dramatists think more like
shakespeare thought but that doesn't
mean that there isn't truth and it just
means that you have to be a little bit
more sophisticated about your ideas of
truth and that's okay you know there are
truths to live by okay well fine then we
want to figure out what those are
because we need to live and maybe not to
suffer so much so so and so as you know
that what the Bible stories and stories
in general are trying to represent is
the lived experience of conscious
individuals like the structure of the
lived experience of conscious
individuals then that opens up the
possibility of a whole different realm
of understanding and eliminates the
contradiction that's been painful for
people between the objective world and
and let's say the claims of religious
stories so okay okay so let's let's
let's take a look at the structure of
the book itself so the first thing about
the Bible is that it's a comedy and a
comedy has a happy ending right so
that's a strange thing because the Greek
god stories were almost always tragic
now the Bible is the comedy it has a
happy ending everyone lives there's a
heaven so now what you think about that
is a completely different issue I'm just
telling you the structure of the story
it's something like there's paradise at
the beginning of time and then some
Cataclysm occurred and people fell into
history and history is limitation and
mortality and suffering and
self-consciousness but there's a mode of
being or potentially the establishment
of the state that will transcend that
and that's what time is aiming at so
that's the that's the idea of the story
now it's a funny thing that the Bible
has a story because it wasn't written at
the book right it was assembled from a
whole bunch of different books and the
fact that it got assembled into
something resembling a story it's quite
remarkable and what the question isn't
well what is that story about and how
did it come up as a story and then I
suppose as well is there anything to it
it constitutes a dramatic record of
self-realization or abstractions or
mentioned that was like the idea for
example of the formulation of the let's
say the image of God is a abstraction
that's how we're going to handle it to
begin with I want to say though because
I said I wasn't going to be any more
reductionist the necessary I know that
the evidence for genuine religious
experience is incontrovertible but it's
not explicable and so I don't want to
explain it away I want to just leave it
as a fact and then I want to pull back
from that and say okay well we'll leave
that as a fact that the mystery and but
we'll look at this we're going to look
at this from a rational perspective and
say that the initial formulation of the
idea of God was an attempt to abstract
out the ideal and to and to consider it
as a abstraction outside its
instantiation so and that's good enough
that's amazing thing if it's true but I
don't want to throw out the baby with
the bathwater let's say it's a
collection of books with multiple
redactors and editors so what does that
mean many people wrote it there's many
different books even and they're inter
woven together especially in the first
five books by people who I suspect took
the traditions of tribes that had been
brought together under a single
political organization and tried to make
their accounts coherent and so it took a
little bit and they took a little of
that and they took a little of this and
they and they tried not to lose anything
because it seemed valuable it was
certainly valuable to the people who had
collected the stories they weren't going
to you know tolerate too much editing
but they also wanted it to make sense to
some degree so it wasn't completely
logically contradictory and and and and
completely absurd and so many people
wrote it and many people edited and many
people assembled it over a vast stretch
of time and we have very few documents
like that and so just because we have a
document like that is it sufficient
reason to to look at it as a remarkable
phenomenon and try to understand what it
is that it's trying to communicate let's
say and then I said it's also the
world's first hyperlinked text which is
which is about again and very much we're
thinking about for quite a long time
all right there's four sources in the
Old Testament or the Hebrew Bible four
stories that we know came together one
was called the priestly the source
called the priestly and it used the name
Elohim or El Shaddai for God and I
believe L is the root word for Ella as
well so and that's usually translated as
God or the gods because Elohim is is
utilized as plural in the beginning
books of the of the of the Bible and
it's newer than the yahwist version now
the reason I'm telling you that is
because Genesis 1 which is the first
story isn't as old as Genesis to Genesis
2 contains the youngest version contains
the story for example of Adam and Eve
and that's older than the very first
book in the Bible but they decided to
put the newer version first and what
isn't and I think it's because it deals
with more fundamental abstractions it's
something like that it's like it deals
with the most basic of abstractions how
the universe was created and then save
ways into what the human environment is
like and so that seems to be the logic
behind it the yahwah's version uses the
name yhw H which apparently people
didn't say but we believe was pronounced
something like yahwah and it it has a
strongly answered amorphic God so one
that takes human form it begins with
Genesis 2:4 this is the account of the
heavens and the earth wind and it
contains the story of Adam and Eve and
Cain and Abel and Noah and the Tower of
Babel and Exodus and numbers alone with
the priestly version it also contains
the law in the form just the form of the
Ten Commandments which is like a
truncated form of the law there's the
elohist source it contains the stories
of Abraham and Isaac it's concerned with
a heavenly hierarchy that includes
angels it talks about the departure from
Egypt and it presents the Covenant code
which is this idea that you know that
society is predicated this was Israeli
society was predicated on a covenant
with God and that's laid out in the
sequence of rules
some of which are the 10 commandments
but many of which are much more
extensive than that and then the final
one is the deuteronomist code and it
contains the bulk of the law and the
what's called the Deuteronomic history
and it's independent of Genesis Exodus
Leviticus and numbers and so we know
that at least for now there's debate
about this like there is about
everything you know so I'm brushing over
a very large area of scholarship but
people generally assume that there were
multiple authors over multiple periods
of time and the way they concluded that
is by looking at textual analysis you
know trying to see where there are
chunks of the stories that have the same
kind of style or the same reference and
people argue about that because you know
obviously it's difficult to recreate
something ancient but that's that's the
basic idea so it is an amalgam of
viewpoints about these initial issues
and that's important to know so it's
like a collective it's a collective
story and okay now to understand the
first part of Genesis I'm going to turn
strangely enough to something that's
actually part of the New Testament and
this is a central element of
Christianity and it's a very strange
idea that's going to take a very long
time to unpack but the idea this is what
John said about Christ he said in the
beginning was the word and so that
relates back to Genesis 1 in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God
Oh some well done you know three
sentences like that take a lot of
unpacking because well none of that
seems to make any sense whatsoever
really right in the beginning was the
word and the word was both with God and
the Word was God so the first question
might be what in the world does that
mean in the beginning was the word
that's the logos actually and the logos
is embodied in the figure of Christ so
there's this idea and John that whatever
Christ is the son of God is not only
instantiated in history say at a
particular time in place as I as a
carpenter in some backwoods part of the
world but also something eternal
that exists outside of time and space
that was there right at the beginning
and as far as I can tell what that logos
represents is something like modern
people something like what modern people
refer to when they talk about
consciousness it's something like that
it's more than that it's like
consciousness and it's capacity to to be
aware and it's capacity to communicate
it's something like that and there's an
idea underneath that which is that being
especially from a phenomenological
perspective so the being that is
experience cannot exist without
consciousness like consciousness shines
a light on things to bring it into being
because without consciousness what is
there no one experiences anything like
is there any is there anything when no
one experiences anything that's the
question and the answer that this book
is presenting is that no you have to
think about consciousness as a
constituent element of reality it's
something that's necessary for reality
itself to exist now of course it depends
on what you mean by reality but the
reality that's being referred to here I
told you already is this strange amalgam
of the subjective experience and the
world but the question is deeper than
that too because it is by no means
obvious what there is if there's no one
to experience it in the whole notion of
time itself seems to collapse at least
in terms of something like felt duration
and then the notion of size disappears
essentially because there's nothing to
scale it and the causality seems to
vanish and so and we don't understand
consciousness not in the least we don't
understand what it is that is in us that
gives illumination to be it and what
happens in the old testament at least in
part is that that consciousness is
associated with the divine now you think
well is that a reasonable proposition
and that's a very complicated question
but at least we might note that there's
something to the claim because there is
a miracle of experience and existence
that's dependent on consciousness I mean
people try to explain it away constantly
but it doesn't seem to work very well
and and here's something else to think
about
I think it's really worth thinking about
people do not like it when you treat
them like they're not conscious right
they react very badly to that and then
you don't like it if someone assumes
that you're not conscious and you don't
like it if someone assumes that you
don't have free will you know that
you're just absolutely determined in
your in your actions and there's nothing
that's going to repair you and that you
don't need to have any responsibility
for your actions it's like our culture
the laws of our culture are predicated
on the idea something like people are
conscious people have experienced people
make decisions and can be held
responsible for them that there's a free
will element to it and you can debate
all that philosophically and fight but
the point is is that that is how we act
and that is the idea that our legal
system is predicated on and there's
something deep about it because you know
you're subject to the law but the law is
also limited by you which is to say that
in a well functioning properly grounded
democratic system you have intrinsic
value that's the source of your right
even if you're a murderer
we have to say the law can only go so
far because there's something about you
that's divine well what does that mean
well partly it means that there's
something about you that's conscious and
capable of communicating like you're a
whole world in unto yourself and you
have that to contribute to everyone else
and that's valuable I mean that you can
learn new things you can transform the
structure of society you can invent a
new way of dealing with the world you're
capable of all that it's an intrinsic
part of you and that's associated with
this it's associated that's the idea
there is that there's something about
the logos that is necessary for the
absolute chaos of the reality beyond
experience to manifest itself as reality
it's an amazing idea because it gives
consciousness a constitutive role in the
cosmos and you can debate that but you
know it's not you can't just bloody well
brush it off because first of all we are
the most complicated things there are
that we know of by by a massive
by a massive amount we're so complicated
that it's unbelievable and so you know
there's a lot of cosmos out there but
there's a lot of cosmos in here too and
which one is greater is by no means
obvious unless you use something trivial
like relative size which you know really
isn't a very sophisticated approach and
whatever is that is you has this
capacity to experience reality and to
transform it which is very strange thing
you know you can conceptualize a future
in your imagination and then you can
work and make that manifest you
participate in the process of creation
that's one way of thinking about it and
so that's why I think in in Genesis 1 it
relates the idea that human beings are
made in the image of the divine men and
women which is interesting too because
you know the feminists are always
criticizing Christianity for example as
being what inexorably patriarchal or if
they criticize everything like that so
it's hardly a stroke of bloody brilliant
but I think it's an absolute miracle
that's right at the beginning of the
document it says straightforwardly like
with no hesitation whatsoever that the
divine spark which were associated with
the word that brings forth being is
manifest in men and women equally that's
a very cool thing and you got to think
well like I said you actually take that
seriously well what you got to ask is
what happens if you don't take it
seriously
right that's reading read Garces Keyes
crime and punishment that's the best the
best investigation of that tactic that's
ever been produced because what happens
in Dostoyevsky's crime and punishment is
that the main character whose name is
Raskolnikov decides that there's no
intrinsic value to other people and that
as a consequence he can do whatever he
wants it's only cowardice that stops him
from acting right because what why would
it be anything else other people if the
value of other people is just an
arbitrary superstition then why can't I
do exactly what I want when I want which
is the Psychopaths viewpoint well a
soldier Skolnick law does it killed
someone who's a very horrible person and
he has very good reasons for killing her
and he's half-starved and a little bit
insane and possessed by this ideology
it's brilliant brilliant leo and he
finds out something after he kills her
which is that the post killing
Raskolnikov and the pre killing miss
skullnick oov are not the same person
even a little bit because he's broken a
rule like he's broken a serious rule and
there's no going back and crime and
punishment is ism is a is the best
investigation I know of of what happens
if you take the notion that there's
nothing divine about the individual
seriously now you know most of the
people I know who are deeply atheistic
and I'm and I understand why they're
deeply atheistic they haven't contended
with people like Dostoevsky not as far
as I can tell because I don't see
logical flaws in crime and punishment I
think he got the psychology exactly
right and he doth yes he's amazing for
this because I mean one of his books The
Devil's for example he describes a
political scene scenario that's not much
different than the one we find yourself
in now and there are these people who
are possessed by rationalistic utopian
atheistic ideas and they're very
powerful they give rise to the communist
revolution right I mean they're powerful
ideas and his character stavrogin also
acts out the presupposition that human
beings have no intrinsic nature and no
intrinsic value and it's Britt another
brilliant investigation and dusk yeskey
prophesized that's what I would say what
will happen to a society if it goes down
that road and he was dead exactly
accurate it's uncanny to read
Dostoyevsky's the possessed or the devil
depending on the translation and then to
read Thunder Solzhenitsyn's Gulag
Archipelago because one is fiction and
prophecy and the second is hey look it
turned out exactly the way the
Dostoyevsky said it would for exactly
the same reasons so it's quite
remarkable so well so the question is do
you contend seriously with the idea that
a there's something cosmically
constitutive about consciousness and B
that that might well be considered
divine and see that that is instantiated
in every person and then ask yourself if
you're not a criminal if you don't act
it out
and then ask yourself what that means is
that reflective of a reality or is it a
metaphor like maybe it's a metaphor a
complex metaphor that we have to use to
organize our societies could well be but
even as a metaphor it's it's true enough
so that we mess with it at our peril and
it also took people a very long time to
figure out this is Genesis one you know
what I'm probably going to stop there
because I believe it's nine-thirty and
so we didn't even get to the first line
[Applause]
yeah yeah look I want to read you a
couple of things that we'll use as a Pro
drama for the next lecture because I'll
just bounce through a collection of
ideas that's associated with the notion
of divinity okay and then we'll turn
back to the first lines when we start
the next like I have no idea how far I'm
going to get through the biblical
stories by the way because I'm trying to
figure this out as I go along okay so
you know there's an idea in Christianity
that's good that the image of God is a
Trinity right there's the father is the
element of the father there's the
element of the sunnat' is the element of
the Holy Spirit is something like
tradition the spirit of tradition it's
something like the human being as the
newest incarnation of that tradition
like the living incarnation of that
tradition and then then it's something
like the spirit in people that makes
relationship with this and this possible
the spirit in individuals and so I'm
going to bounce my way quickly through
some of the classical metaphorical
attributes of God so that we kind of
have a cloud of notions about what we're
talking about when we return to Genesis
1 and talk about the God who spoke chaos
into being so there's a fatherly aspect
so here's what God as a father is like
you can enter into a covenant with it so
you can make a bargain with it now you
think about that money is like that
because money is a bargain you make with
the future right so we start
to our world so that you can negotiate
with the future and I don't think that
we would have got to the point where we
could do that without having this idea
to begin with you can you can act as if
the futures a reality there's a spirit
of tradition that enables you to act as
if the future is something that can be
bargained with that's why you make
sacrifices right and the sacrifices were
acted out for a very long period of time
and now there's psychological we know
that you can sacrifice something
valuable in the present and expect that
you're negotiating with something that
represents the transcendent future and
that's a map amazing human discovery
like no other creature can do that to
act as if the future is real to note
that you can bargain with reality itself
and that you can do it successfully
it's unbelievable it responds to
sacrifice it answers prayers I'm not
saying that any of this is true by the
way I'm just saying what the what the
cloud of ideas represents it punishes
and rewards it judges and forgives it's
not nature you see the thing about the
thing that's one of the things that's
weird about the judeo-christian
tradition is that God and nature are not
the same thing at all whatever God is
partially manifest in this logos is
something that stands outside of nature
and that's I think that's something like
consciousness as abstracted from the
natural world so it built even for
mankind and then banished us for
disobedience
it's too powerful to be touched it
granted free will distance from it is
hell distance from it is death it
reveals itself in dogma and in mystical
experience and it's the law so that's
sort of like the fatherly aspect and
then the sun-like aspect it speaks chaos
into order it slays dragons and feeds
people with the remains it finds gold it
rescues virgins it's the body and blood
of Christ it's a tragic victim and
scapegoat and eternally Triana
triumphant Redeemer simultaneously it
cares for the outcasts it dies it is
reborn it's the king of kings and hero
of heroes it's not the state but both is
both the fulfillment and critic of the
state it dwells in the perfect house it
is aiming at paradise
to heaven it can rescue from hell it
cares for the outcast it's the
foundation stone and the cornerstone
that was rejected and it's the spirit of
the law and then it's spirit like it's
akin to the human soul it's the
prophetic voice it's the still small
voice of conscience
it's the spoken truth it's called forth
by music it is the enemy of deceit
arrogance and resentment it's the water
of life
it burns without consuming and it's a
blinding light ok so that's a very
that's a very well-developed poetic set
of poetic metaphors essentially right so
these are all what would you say
glimpses of the transcendent ideal
that's the right way of thinking about
their glimpses of the transcendent ideal
and all of them have a specific meaning
and well in part what we're going to do
is go over that meaning as we continue
with this with this series and so what
we've got now is a brief description at
least of what this is in the beginning
God created the heavens and the earth we
know it's associated with the logos in
this sequence of stories we know it's
associated with the word and with
consciousness and we know that it's
associated with whatever God is and then
I laid out the the metaphoric landscape
that at least in part describes God and
so now we have some sense of the being
that does this creates the heavens and
the earth the earth was without form and
void that's that chaotic state of
intermingled confusion the darkness was
over the face of the deep and the Spirit
of God was hovering over the face of the
waters and God said let there be light
and there was light and so we'll stop
with that because now we're ready to
take a tentative step into the very
first part of this book and it's
important to have your conceptual
framework properly organized so that you
can appreciate where it's going and what
it might possibly meet and so well I've
done what I can today - what would you
say elaborate on this single word I
suppose and
but it's a big word you know so hmm
it's not so unreasonable that it takes a
long time to get to the point where you
have any sense of what it means at all
all right that is nowhere near that is
not I thought I would get a lot for it
all right
so thank you very much
[Applause]
so we do have time for some questions we
have to be out of here at 10:30 it's
9:30 so maybe we'll have questions until
kind of someone crazy grubs microphone
and or maybe we'll have questions for
half an hour something like that and so
if anybody has any questions then
there's a microphone there and there's a
microphone there and I'll try to answer
them to the best that I can
mister my ability so let's sure let's
start okay so you talked about the idea
of when you're confronting something
that you fear you like you face it
head-on and you you destroy it but then
you said that that is when you're
confronting something you make the world
out of it and I was wondering if you
could just I mean they expound me that
means you make your marriage out of the
arguments okay you know you have
arguments with your wife you have
arguments with your children that's that
chaotic state because no one's being
able to formulate a habitable order from
that that domain of controversy and
confusion and then through dialogue you
erect the structure that's a house that
you can both live in and so that's the
that's the idea of making the world out
of that chaos and it's it's frightening
because you know if you're really
happened this is why people often avoid
having disputes with people they love
because it's frightening right you find
out what the person's like and you find
out what you're like it's like God who
wants to do that nobody and so you know
your heart rate goes up and it's
confrontation and conflict and and
that's because you're encountering that
domain that hasn't been properly mapped
or considered and so and you're doing
that with your predator detection
systems essentially and so that chaos
that the threat is the stability say of
the marriage is equivalent to well it's
equivalent to the serpent in the tree
that's one form of equivalence and then
by dialogue through dialogue and
negotiation you formulate the problem
what exactly is going on here where
exactly are we what exactly is the
problem and so you keep talking until
you reach a consensus
when you can live with one that you can
act out right and then you then maybe
you come up with a solution to the
problem and you've established peace
again in peace that's the house that you
can both live in and that's the chaos
that's the chaos that people can fall
into all the time and often do and it's
the chaos that makes a marriage wash up
on the shores and transform into like
you know 50-year divorce court very
horrible thing so that's the idea okay
thank you okay hi dr. Pearson thank you
so much for the talk and thanks for your
teachings it's really helped me a lot of
how to experience in grad school to
English degrees and the way you describe
to the humanities in my experience
helped me understand my experience back
then so thank you so that's too bad next
too bad did that happen communicate
really like that you know it's really
not good but you don't have to tell me
that yeah yeah but you know I survived
and I learned a lot and you know I'm not
you know ungrateful for my experience
I've learned a lot but you said
something you described a Bible the
collection of stories in the Bible
interesting way and I wonder if it was
on purpose you described it as created
by an assembly of stories created by
many people over time the type of length
into itself and it sounds a lot like how
a description of like the Internet and
like how that works yeah well it's not
it's not accidental I mean because the
Internet's also a collective it's a
collective endeavor god only knows what
personality it's going to manifest you
know but it's going to manifest some
personality because it's learning to
understand us very very rapidly so I
think you could there's no reason not to
think about it as a precursor I mean the
distance between the Bible and the
Internet is a lot less than the distance
between a chimpanzee as a human being so
and the difference between a book and
the Internet is it's also it's in some
sense it's a matter of matter of degree
rather than kind so
I I can't speculate you know because god
only knows what's going to happen in the
next 20 years
I certainly don't and so I don't know
what the preconditions are for
consciousness I have no idea and I don't
think anybody knows so I guess we're
going to find out so yep yep hey dr.
Peterson I'm curious about the
connection between aesthetic beauty and
religious experience I think you've
hinted at it once or twice over the
courses lecture is it possible for
something that's incredibly beautiful to
evoke a religious or mystical experience
or something in the same ballpark I
think that's what they're for yeah not a
chance
no I mean if you look at the doctor of
like like a Renaissance Cathedral you
know II was just gonna write right off
my my tag on till I apologize me to drop
my tag on that question the next part
was um is that why we have cathedrals
built like a spectacular buildings as a
book yeah well it's Oxford right well
it's if you're going to house the
ultimate ideal you build something
beautiful right to to represent its
dwelling place and it should be
beautiful and this is something that
people do not take seriously and this is
especially something we don't take
seriously in Canada I mean one of you
think about you think about all the
hundreds of millions of dollars that
were invested into beauty in Europe in
the spectacular excessive investment in
beauty that's paid back god only knows
how many multiples of times people make
pilgrimages to Europe constantly because
it's so beautiful that it just it
staggers you Beauty is so valuable and
we're so afraid of it and I think we're
afraid of it because it does it's a
pathway it's not the only pathway to the
divine I mean there's a lot there's
pathways to the divine love is one of
them I suppose but beauty especially for
people who have an affinity
four beauties it's like music it's one
of those things that you can't argue
against right you can't even understand
it just hits you and and it does it
shows you well it shows you the ideal
that's one way of thinking about it but
it also shows you I think it's like a
vision of the potential future it's
something like that as well that if we
just got our act together and and
beautified things that that's the place
that we can inhabit and that would in
noble us and that's why this Jerusalem
heavily City is paved with gemstones you
know their crystalline the emit light
and yeah it's the proper dwelling place
for an enlightened consciousness beauty
is the proper dwelling place for an
enlightened consciousness and we we
ignore it at our spiritual and economic
peril it's like it's obvious that beauty
there's almost nothing more valuable
than beauty economically practically
right so yeah why that is I mean I don't
it's very who knows you know I mean why
we we experience gemstones for example
as beautiful it's very mysterious but
there are deep reasons for it so yeah hi
I have a bit of a similar question
actually um I know what one of the ways
in which the Bible is appreciated even
by you some of its harshest critics and
deeply atheistic people is as a work of
literature and n is something I'm at
least the King James or the authorized
translation the Bible is something very
aesthetically beautiful and a great work
of literature and a great work of poetry
and I'm wondering just from your study
of it and from your personal perspective
if there's any any particular passages
or our parts of it do you find
particularly I have struck you in that
way or that you do cherish more than
more than any others because you be able
to share well the ones that have really
open the ones that have really opened up
to me I think are the stories in Genesis
right up to the Tower of Babel because I
think well and hopefully I'll be able to
talk to all of you about that but I
think I got some sense of what they mean
and why I mean I know it's not
exhaustive and obviously but like and
then there Nestorian Exodus as well I
so filled it like I've got a handle on
that and so those of those have hit me
really really hard and that you know I
mean just trying to understand this
first part of Genesis to try to
understand what these concepts mean has
been especially when I started to
understand that the concept that human
beings are made in God's image at God it
has all those attributes that we just
described but human beings are made in
God's image that that's actually the
cornerstone of our legal system not
really that really rattled me because I
didn't understand that clearly that our
body of laws has that metaphysical
presupposition without which the laws
fall apart and that's starting to happen
it really is you know like the
postmodern critique of law the law
schools are I would say they're overrun
by post modernists who are undermining
the structure of Western law as fast as
they possibly can because they don't buy
any of this and so they're much more
likely to just think of the law as
something like a like a casual pragmatic
tool to be manipulated for the purposes
of bringing forth the Utopia it's a
really really really bad idea so it's
very strange to me that we go off track
when metaphysical foundation starts to
get rattled so do you think your your
appreciation of the aesthetic studium it
comes from a belief in like the truth of
its underlying propositions I mean that
because like even the atheistic critics
I'm thinking of like like even Dawkins
or kitchens really appreciate the Bible
it has just a piece of really beautiful
literature and I guess the quality of
their writing and certain exalted themes
behind it even if they totally reject
the underlying premise of it you seem
good yeah well I don't think that you
can see it as beautiful and poetic with
the end reject the underlying premises
because if you see it as beautiful and
poetic you're accepting the underlying
premises with your experience of the
beauty and the poetics even though you
may be maybe fighting it with your
articulated rationality so I think all
that indicates is a dis integrated
perspective on the book and I'm not it's
not surprising that that's the case I
mean it's the perspective that everyone
has on the book except with them it's
more well developed and well thought
through but I think it's fundamental
they're not approaching the thing with
enough respect that's my senses they and
who knows right because I don't I don't
know but what I've tried to do is to
think there's probably more to this than
I know and then try to understand it
from that perspective rather than to
think for example log2 collection of of
superstitions that we've somehow
outgrown it's like no it's just
sorry that's that's not a deep enough
analysis because it's got some truth but
it doesn't take into account the fact
that the proposition still stand at the
foundation of our culture it doesn't
address Nietzsche's central concern
which is that if you blow out the notion
of God the entire structure crumbles you
know on you can debate that fine
but I just you know just assume that you
debated it with Nietzsche because he's a
pretty tough customer to tangle with so
I don't think that the Atheist types
insofar as there's a type I don't think
they've wrestled with the real problems
so yeah
[Applause]
so I appreciate you set up some ground
rules keep things rational and I think
that's going to help us what I'm
wondering is so for instance you said
elsewhere the New Testament from the
best from what you can see it's
psychologically correct and that's you
know quite astounding I would say
there's a lot of truth and in in your
depictions of these stories elsewhere
you've pointed out like deep truths you
know they're real powerful so what my
question would be is if we can say
Nietzsche took a like an order of
magnitude of you know intelligence and
you know depth to be able to predict
what would happen in the next century
you know rationally if the Bible is not
the inerrant Word of God what's going on
that's a good question that's a really
good question I mean I'm going to try to
answer that rationally but but and as we
move forward but as I said I don't want
to leave people with the notion because
you know some ways it's something I've
thought about what I've been thinking
about for a long time is I can't tell if
I'm a like an advocate of the religious
viewpoint or its worst possible critic
because I am doing my best to make it
rational and there's a reductionistic
element to that but I think that I'm
doing that while also leaving the door
open to things that I don't understand
because I know that there's there's more
to this story than I understand or can
understand and I'm laying out what I can
understand and I'm making it rational
but I do not believe for an instant that
that exhausts the realm it's like there
are ways of interpreting these stories
that work in the conceptual universe we
inhabit right now but there's a lot of
things that we don't understand and what
I'm the thing I've found about digging
into these stories is that the deeper
you dig the more you find and that's
pretty damaged that's one of the things
that convinced me that there was more to
them that I had originally suspected
because things would click and I think
wow that's true that's really something
and then I would take it apart further
and I think whole well I thought that
was something but this is this is even
more remarkable it just keeps opening
and opening and so I'm going to make it
so I'm going to try to provide an answer
to and it is I think you're right about
speaking about Nietzsche and his
capacity for prophecy and Dostoyevsky's
in the same category like there are
prophetic elements to the old and new
Testament that seemed to stretch over
much vaster spans of time and I'm going
to try to produce a rational account of
that but it mean one of the reasons that
I think the New Testament is
psychologically true let's say is
because and this is one of the things
that's that's that's deeply embedded in
the structure of the Bible in the Old
Testament there's this idea of I'm
skipping ahead that through a succession
of states the people who behave properly
will eventually establish the proper
state and so the state is viewed in some
sense as the of the entity of salvation
but what happens in the New Testament is
that idea gets you could say
deconstructed and instead of a state
being the place of redemption a state of
being becomes the state of redemption
and so the idea that human beings will
be redeemed moves from a utopian state
vision to the responsibility of the
individual and I think that's correct I
mean I believe that that's the right
answer and I think that the West in
particular is predicated on idea that
idea because it makes the state
subservient to the individual I mean as
a is what a dialog continual dialogue
but in the final analysis the locus of
the divine is the individual not the
state and I believe that that's so true
that if we don't act it out and believe
it then we all die painfully and that's
true enough for me so
I thank you for illuminating talk I'm
going to keep you on the creation story
and if you don't mind because we know
the editing that was done there was the
purpose for the editing can you give us
your thoughts about the difference in
the story of creation especially
pertaining to men from the first chapter
which is very godlike you know by a word
and to the second one which is more like
a fatherly type of creation is it the
selling point what was the reason for
this type of editing to put the two
together why not well I think you know
the more cynical would call critic
criticisms of the Bible and the
religious tradition criticisms like
Marx's or Freud's even for that matter
make the case that it's a power it's a
manifestation of power in politics and
and that there's always a political or
economic motivation behind the
construction of the stories and I think
that that's true to some degree but I
don't think that it's true enough so
that you can take that particular
interpretive tack and be done with it
and I would say that to the degree that
there are political and economic
motivations that have shaped the stories
the fact that multiple stories have come
together they're sort of corrective in
some sense and so even at the level of
detail there's political intrigue and
politics say with regards to the
ascendancy of Israel when you step away
from it it becomes something that's more
Universal and escapes from that and how
that happened I don't know I mean I
think it's safe to say it's reasonably
safe to say that the people who put this
document together they did two things I
think they were guided by their
aesthetic taste and their conscience I
truly believe that and the reason I
believe that is because I think anything
that was propagandistic would have been
forgotten and he can't remember
propaganda no one likes it it's like
it's dead ten years after you write over
20 years and it isn't only that these
books were assembled in written it was
that they were preserved and remembered
and to me that means they have enough
entity with the structure of memory I
mean you think about how does this story
last 10,000 years unless it's the kind
of story you can remember it doesn't
because you forget all the forgettable
stuff and all you remember is the
memorable stuff and so there's this
there's this interplay between the
document itself and its audience that
shapes the document and so now I don't
know how specifically I answered your
question we're going to hit the
different stories as they come up in
sequence and I think I'll shed some more
light on the relationship between them
I'm doing that and we'll start with that
next week okay right so I've been really
interested in a lot of the stuff that
you've been saying about dreams because
I've been lucid dreaming a lot for many
years but always in a sort of a theistic
way it's sort of like a game or
something like that but because of
seeing your talk and everything I've
started to think of it from a different
perspective like you're now interfacing
with something beyond the narrow scope
of your conscious awareness that or
something like that maybe mythological
or maybe something like God and so what
I've been thinking about and what it may
be wonder what you think about it is
that in some way is when you're lucid
dreaming you're kind of Trent you're
getting beyond lived in limitations of
an ordinary dream you're sort of
transcending limitations which maybe is
like it's not the purpose of people
right is it because as a person you're
supposed to be limited in some way as
opposed to like God Ruiz like not
limited and how but on the other hand
it's a good opportunity to kind of have
control over your interactions with this
like very special and like interesting
thing so I guess the conundrum is that
on one hand like you can you can control
your interactions but on the other hand
like you are controlling them so I guess
I'm wondering what you think about that
and also just in general what do you
think about lucid dreaming is a thing
like should you do it or I had a client
who could really lucid dream you know
and one of the things she used them now
and then to solve problems even though
she didn't always pay attention to the
answer
sometimes she did
she wanted her in one of her dreams one
of the characters told her that she
would have to learn to live in a
slaughterhouse she was very afraid of
life and one of the consequences of that
was that we went watched an embalming so
so the dreams were but one of the things
she did she'd asked the characters what
they were up to you know she was instead
of controlling she would inquire and so
but I don't know what to say about lucid
dreaming beyond that like I know it's a
well-documented phenomena and many
people can do it and women seem to be
able to do it better than men that's
what the research indicates but I think
that what we don't know about lucid
dreaming could fill a lot of books so I
think you do there is some danger in
controlling it I think because you lose
the spontaneous revelation although not
completely because you can't control it
completely but I like see you might be
interested in reading Jung's works on
active imagination because he kind of
learned to dream when he was awake and
he spent a lot of time in the world of
imagination when he was awake the red
books for example the red book is a
document of his experiences with awake
dreaming but he was very interactive
with the dream you know instead of
trying to bend it to his grandma's will
he was he was exploring it in some sense
like you'd explore a videogame you know
which are forms of Dreams in and of
themselves so yeah I would say do it
with an exploratory purpose in mind you
could always ask yourself what you could
learn too which is a very dangerous
question to ask a dream because
sometimes you'll find out what you have
to learn that's not so pleasant but it's
really worthwhile okay yes
okay so I think I think I'm going to
take four more questions only because
I'm running out of braids and I don't
want to say stupid things or stupider
things that I've already said so so yeah
thank you for the talk in the beginning
of your lecture you talked about how
society needed this kind of dreamlike
religious base so we don't go between
left and right violently and we can kind
of have this base and then you also said
you admired Nietzsche for kind of
chopping down these these ideological
and kind of dogmatic weeds coming up
from the base of Christianity
I was wondering how what your thoughts
are on how society can have this kind of
religious base without having these kind
of dangerous ideologies that can spring
up once in a while that's what I'm
trying to figure out no really I mean
that really that's the serious answer to
that question you know I mean the reason
that I'm an admirer of Nietzsche is
because he was the spirit of his time so
that's a good way of thinking about it
it's not like Nietzsche killed God it's
that Nietzsche gathered what was in the
air and articulated it right incredibly
profoundly and so he put his finger on
the spot and now in doing so he
announced the problem and once you
announced the problem then maybe you can
come up with a solution because you
can't solve a problem unless you know
what it is and the fact that he made it
so stark and so clear is horrifying in
some sense but at least we know where we
stand
and so since then I would say
particularly with in many ways
particularly with the work of yoga and
everything that's come out of that which
is a deeper study of mythology and its
meanings and we've been trying to
address that the issue that needs you
brought up and trying to solve the
problem the problem is something like
the reunification of the spirit of
mankind it's something like that well
we're slogging through it man and that's
that's that that's why you're all here
at least in part so we'll see how far we
can get by at this rate we'll get to
like the 12th verse in the first
yeah but that same you know okay
[Applause]
yes they'll be in they'll be in the
video I could also make them available
add slides yeah well that's okay I'll
return to this when we when we get going
again so oh yeah different colors
represent the distance between the
between the cross references yeah well
there I'll talk about that more next
time I mean I think that the best answer
to that is I'll talk more about that
next time I mean I think of them as
overlapping metaphorical domains you
know in the descriptions I put of the
fatherly aspect that some aspect in the
spirit aspect you can swap a lot of
those you know it's kind of arbitrary
but I think they're I think the
trinitarian idea is trying to get
forward the notion that the locus of the
divine is is it's the same thing in its
essence but it exists in a multiplicity
it exists as the spirit of tradition it
exists as the living individual in the
end time and space and then it it exists
as the spirit that well and as
consciousness something like that that
we all share which which you know you
would have thought about that is
something like the capacity for the
individual to realize that tragedy and
redemption of Christ in their individual
life and that's something like your
capacity to voluntarily accept the
tragic conditions of your existence and
to move forward to something resembling
paradise regardless of that you know as
something that's intrinsic to you and I
think that's associated with the idea of
the Pentecost and and and the Holy
Spirit all of that it's it's so that's
as good as I can do in a short
of time so yep I think it's because it's
because of the gap between what we
articulate and what we don't know
something has to fill that gap like I
think the law could be could could
replace it if the law was total but it
isn't it's it's bounded and incorrect
and there's something arrests it has to
rest on something inside that's like
this mediator between what we articulate
and what we don't understand it's
something like custom it's something
like expectation it's something like the
intrinsic sense of justice you know that
the law itself is aiming at and those
aren't fully articulated but without
them there'd be no grounding like
without the body the law would be a
dictionary you know and if you don't
know what a word means using the
dictionary is helpful but not that
helpful because like unless you've had
the experience of anger the dictionary
can't tell you what anger means it's
just refers to other words but the words
themselves refer to something else and
the law refers to something else and
without that it has to be in tune with
that something else and has to be in
accordance with it and so I I don't
think we can ever delineate the proper
body of laws and that's also why you
like ideological utopias see the unity
illogical utopia is dispensed with the
transcendent they say this is what we
need to do it's like no you don't know
that's not good you have to leave space
for what you kind of know and for what
you don't know and I mean you know in
the story of the Tower of Babel human
beings make this massive building that's
supposed to reach up to the heavens so
that it'll take the place of God well
that's that's the earliest warning we
have of the danger of making things so
big that you confuse them with God and
God gets irritated and comes down and
makes everybody speak
four languages and scatters them it's
like well that's what happens when you
try to make something a totality is that
it starts to fragment inside and and
disintegrates into catastrophe and so
it's almost as if we have to maintain
this articulated space inside the dream
inside the custom something like that
because otherwise it doesn't work
and I think that's the same as having
respect for the fact that we have bodies
you know we're not just abstract
creatures that follow rules
we're not that at all we only follow
certain rules we won't follow the other
ones and our societies will crumble and
so and we just don't know enough to
articulate the entire landscape of
behavior with articulated rules not at
all we can't do it it's beyond us yeah
yeah okay thanks for the talk my
question is also about dreams you spoke
about dreams as like a representation of
truths and universal truths that can be
interpreted into like myths and and
religion and as as you say it's very
beneficial for the individual and it
sounds like also for for the society as
well because not everyone can as easily
remember their dreams or interpret their
dreams like that and also it's it's like
broadcasted to to all of society for
their benefit so I guess I'm wondering
what the evolutionary advantage of
dreams are and my question would be do
you think that dreams suggest some sort
of evolutionary group selection so
should I like groups that don't have
these dreams that are represented into
myths and religion do you think they
they didn't survive as well okay so I'm
not going to answer the second part of
that question because I'd have to go far
too far off at a tangent for me to
manage right now but I can answer the
first part I mean what happens when
you're dreaming there's a little switch
so to speak in your brain that shuts off
when you're dreaming and it stops you
from moving right it shuts everything
except your eyes because who you know if
you're moving your eyes back and forth
is not going to get run around and get
eaten by a lion it's okay to move your
eyes but the rest of you is stand
exactly where it is then you can run
these simulations and so what's
happening at night and this is a fairly
well accepted theory of dreaming we know
that dreams update memories and help
consolidate memories they also help you
forget but what seems to be happening at
night is that you're you're running the
underlying architecture of your
cognitive ability in different
simulations babbling on its cost-free
because you're you're paralyzed you
don't running around they're out in the
world investigating so it's part of the
manner in which your brain experiments
with the way the world can be
represented and so and it seems
absolutely necessary and I mean if you
deprive people of REM sleep they don't
stay sane very long there's something
necessary about the Dreaming process to
maintenance of the of articulated sanity
so you're doing some kind of
organization at night when you descend
into that chaos and partly what seems to
happen is that your categorical you know
your categories have boundaries right
sometimes you don't have the categories
correct and so the boundaries have to
loosen and other things need to be put
into categories or some things shunted
away and in the dream the category
structure loosens which is why dreams
are so peculiar but they're
experimenting it's your mind is
experimenting with the underlying
categorical structure of imagination and
trying to update your your mode of being
in the world dreams often concentrate on
things that provoke anxiety so if you
wake people up when they're dreaming the
most commonly reported emotion is
anxiety and so the dream is like the
first stages of the attempt to contend
with the unknown and so the dream is
half unknown and half known which is
also why it's so peculiar you know
because you kind of understand it but
you don't really and it partakes up the
unknown and of the known and it's the
bridge between the two something like
that so
[Applause]
okay so my question is kind of two parts
the first one is just like a general
question and then just the application
of the question so my first question is
do you think that consciousness and
being hood are in extra inextricably
linked and then secondly so if there was
something like a supercomputer that one
could house theoretically a perfect
brain of a person in it does that thing
then become the same person as the
person who is before so is there a
transcendency to being good but not too
conscious okay so the first question is
well I would say that the kind of being
that these stories are concerned with is
absolutely dependent on consciousness
now whether or not that means that being
as such is dependent on consciousness
actually depends on how you define being
right so it's always tricky when you ask
and it is a an instant an example of B
those are tricky questions because it
depends on how you define the two but
for our purposes the being that we're
discussing that's represented in these
stories is intrinsically associated with
conscious experience and consciousness
has given this constitutive role it says
that the experience that we're talking
about would not exist if consciousness
did not exist so you can think about it
as a kind of game in a way and then you
have to decide for yourself whether
that's a game that can be generalized
and I won't answer the second part okay
if you don't mind all right
[Applause]
so two-part question first ones very
quick almost admin if we want to read
the biblical stories that kind of be
referring to as a particular version
edition source publisher we should refer
to all bring the thing I like next week
which is a I think the Reader's Digest
published it of all things but it's a it
lays out the narratives in a different
format it's easy I find it much easier
to read so I'll show it to you and I'll
bring it next time and show it to you
one of the main reasons I'm interested
in so much of your work and I think many
people are as well as that you kind of
leave literalism at the door and you
open up another door to a much more
deeper meaning in your interview with
transluminal media you mentioned
disciples book the serpent the treatise
yeah yeah and envision and you note that
we as a species are very good at
recognizing camouflage patterns of
snakes particularly in the lower field
of vision and you further note that
visual acuity is correlated with that
and that it co-evolved and you summarize
thusly by saying the following down
paraphrasing you say what gives you
vision snakes - that's what it says in
Genesis what else gives you vision fruit
that's also right that's why we have
color vision what makes you
self-conscious fear man woman that's Eve
and so I understand at the elementary
level some of the concepts that you have
about representations dreams
abstractions etc but kind of raises the
question for me you know I'm not
accusing of any creationism or
literalism yeah you know what's your
point why did you make that connection
what's the meaning of the story of
Genesis visa vie Liz eigvals book no
problem we're gonna as soon as I get
past this first Genesis one we're going
to we're going to hit that hard so so
well hardly
yes I'm suggesting that it foreshadowed
it and and I think they're the same
thing I mean is Beldon her books plays
with that idea metaphorically but she
never really takes it seriously which is
no problem I mean there's only so much
you could take seriously and she did a
fine job of what you did but I'll talk
about that a lot because it's a very
complicated issue I mean I would say to
begin with it
that the systems that you use to deal
with radical uncertainty are the same
systems that your primate ancestors
evolved to deal with snakes that's a
good start
so okay okay one more and then we're
done I'm an aerospace science engineer
and an expert computer programmer and I
have three rapid-fire questions so I'm
going to get through them quick based on
your opinion of where the universities
now stand in terms of humanities and
social sciences it's mathematics more
powerful than articulated speech I'm not
sure I'm not exactly sure how the first
oh well it depends on what you mean by
power I guess I mean obviously studying
mathematics and computer science makes
you insanely powerful the question is to
what end and I don't think that you can
extract an answer to that from the study
of mathematics the humanities are there
to ground people in proper citizen hood
that's that's a way of thinking about it
and so yes it makes you powerful but
then the question is who has the power
because it might not be you it might be
the mathematics so to speak you know
because you never know what you're an
agent of precisely and so yeah well look
I've got nothing against computer
programmers I mean more power to you
guys and mathematicians as well but that
yes and it has to be a truth right it
has to be a tool of something and what
the humanities were forward to Tate was
to tell people what the tools should be
used for and so the tools themselves are
easily powerful but that's that's not
necessarily you know untrammeled good so
I have to stop because okay quick
already want to answer this question
okay okay you were in this I guess one
room in a museum in New York dancing
some original Renaissance artwork
masterpiece yeah these are generally
accepted as amazing artifacts okay does
an original work of art as opposed to a
high fidelity reproduction contained the
spirit of the artist who created it and
does this account for the disparity and
how much you'd have to pay for it does
in part I'm going to a good portrait
artist II and one of the things he
pointed out about a great portrait is
that it actually contains time so you
know because the photograph is one
instant but a portrait is you layered on
you layered on you late so it's got a
thickness you know and I think you can
see that thickness in the original but
it's also a direct manifestation of that
creative active perception I don't think
you get that you just can't get the
fidelity of the original with the
reproduction but there's more to it than
that too because the painting doesn't
end with the frame you know like we tend
to think of the painting itself as the
object but but most objects are are
densely innervated with hist with
historical context and you can say well
the historical context isn't the object
but it depends on what you mean by the
object and often people when they buy a
piece of a painting are buying the
historical context and you just don't
get that with the reproduction it's a
kind of magic it's like you want to have
Elvis Presley's guitar or another guitar
just like it well you want to have
Elvis's guitar that's why you can't tell
it's all of us as guitar by looking at
it well it is at the level of detail but
not at the level of context that's how
it looks to me okay we got to go
thank you
you